mes bien chers abonnés pardonnez moi car
j'ai péché oui
stop science a péché d'avarice depuis
qu'ils ont acheté un micro ils font
n'importe quoi ça a changé stop science
maintenant maintenant ils osent des
croûtes funding finances des financement
participatif pour aller piller des
fossiles sur le terrain maintenant non
évidemment qu'on va pas piller des
fossiles sur le terrain je travaille en
afrique du sud et il nous faut de
l'argent pour pouvoir aller sur le
terrain pour entraîner nos étudiants
donc non on va pas piller vous inquiétez
pas vous inquiéter pas par contre on va
emmener cédric jurassique
donc on va emmener cédric jurassique
donc ça peut être vachement marrant on
va l'initier en même temps que nos
étudiants à la paléontologie et ce qui
est bien c'est que c'est complètement
raccord avec ce que je vais faire
aujourd'hui parce qu'aujourd'hui dans
des bunkers et pénitence je m'attaque à
un site créationnistes hand soir in
genesis la réponse dans la genèse et
puis justement puisqu'on parle du
crowdfunding si vous avez des potes
créationnistes bon déjà va falloir vous
interroger sur la qualité de vos potes
mais si vous avez des potes
créationnistes et bien vous pouvez nous
les envoyer pour la modique somme de
3000 euros
on les amène dans le karoo en afrique du
sud et on vous les initie à la
paléontologie de terrain le mieux c'est
encore que ce soient eux mêmes qui
mettent la tune un bon après c'est vous
qui voyez hein si vous avez vraiment
envie de faire des cadeaux à vos potes
créationnistes voilà on les initie à la
paléontologie terrain on va les faire
creuser pour trouver des fossiles des
véritables fossiles de terra psid et
d'autres reptiles du permien et puis ils
vont faire ça en gros ils vont creuser
une fois qu'ils auront bien creuser 400
mètres de roche 400 mètres cubes de
roche pour pouvoir déterré un fossile
ben là ils se seront rendus compte que
les fossiles c'est des vrais et que
c'est pas nous qui les avons mis là pour
pour servir un dessin darwinia franc
maçonnique démoniaque
voilà donc donc voilà si vous avez si
vous connaissez des créationnistes et
que vous voulez nous les envoyer il n'y
a pas de souci on l'a déjà fait on a
déjà emmené du créationnistes sur le
terrain il ya deux ans j'avais un
étudiant créationnistes on l'emmenait
sur le terrain ça s'est bien passé il
est parvenu complètement convertis
à la paléontologie à l'évolution je le
dirai évidemment mais il est revenu en
ayant des réponses à des questions qui
se posaient et notamment ben voilà il a
bien il a pu voir de ses yeux que c'est
pas nous qui anteryon les fossiles à 400
mètres de profondeur
c'est voilà donc donc voilà on accueille
les créationnistes aussi y'a pas de
soucis dans la mesure l'argent n'a pas
d'odeur voilà et l'argent créationnistes
est encore plus agréable à dépenser que
l'argent des autres
donc allez-y partager le projet trine
axe sur la page de vos sur la page de
vos de vos camarades créationnistes
alors je sais que le projet déjà financé
à 100 % mais on va mettre à nouveau un
nouvel objectif
un objectif qui se rapproche de 150%
afin de faire venir une paléobotaniste
ce qui n'était pas prévu originellement
dans le premier budget et afin de faire
venir plus d'étudiants parce que ça
devait être limité que aux étudiants
honors cherchez pas c'est un truc qui
n'existe pas en france les étudiants au
nord mais on veut aussi de l'ouvrir aux
étudiants en master et aux étudiants et
aux doctorants
donc voilà allez-y partager le projet
trine axe sur les pages créationnistes
fait venir des créationnistes on les
attend et en parlant de créationnistes
c'est parti pour en dessous et regenesis
chapitre xii que sont vraiment devenus
les dinosaures
ça veut dire qu'il ya onze chapitres
avant ça je vais pas tous me les farcir
déjà que celui là il est [ __ ] de
longer vraiment pas envie de lire
non mais regardez moi la longueur de
cette horreur cette vidéo va être longue
elle va être très très longues et
surtout en dessous regenesis c'est les
papilles du créationnistes sur internet
donc en gros tu peux pas test grande
soirée une genesis quoi tous les
arguments qu'on va voir je suis sûr
qu'on les ait déjà vu des milliers de
fois parce que tout le monde les arts
pompé au moins il ya un truc qui est sûr
c'est que à la question qui est david et
qui est goliath
c'est eux les goliath je veux dire 461
me like sur facebook sur leur page
facebook en soirée une genesis ya pas de
doute ils nous battent je dire c'est sûr
ils ont des titres magnifiques sur
facebook com
voilà embrace in god's design for
sexually ti voilà embrasse on en
acceptons le dessin de le design de dieu
pour la sexualité donc voilà azizi à
vagin et vous faites l'amour je sais pas
c'est pas ça le design de dieu pour le
pour la sexualité l'échidné voilà
l'évolution n'arrive pas à expliquer ce
petit ce petit creuseurs épineux c'est
parce que le créateur l'a fait comme
aucun autre animal
aucun autre animal à part peut-être
l'ornithorynque mais ça bon on va pas en
parler on va pas parler des proches
parents des kinés puisque proche parent
implique évolution n'est ce pas donc
c'est parti pour en sourire une genesis
chapitre 2 que sont vraiment devenus les
dinosaures
la bible nous fournit un cadre
permettant de situer les dinosaures sur
une période de quelques milliers
d'années
j'insiste sur milliers d'années
évidemment et non pas millions et
d'élucider le mystère qui entoure la
chronologie de leur existence
5 ainsi que de leur sort final donc la
bible nous dit qu'en vécu les dinosaures
comment qui sont morts spoiler alert
ça doit être le déluge les dinosaures
servent surtout à l'endoctrinement des
enfants comme des adultes à l'idée que
la terre aurait des millions d'années
d'existence
oui alors les dinosaures concept créé en
1842 par soeur ricciardo wen
la datation absolue la première méthode
qui permettait de donner une date aux
dinosaures en millions d'années c'est
dans les années 50
je crois que les premiers papiers ça
devait être en 1950 1952 il ya plus de
cent ans entre l'invention du mot
dinosaures enfin la création du mot
dinosaures et la première datation en
millions d'années donc déjà la première
phrase c'est osef l'endoctrinement des
enfants à l'idée qu' il y aurait des
millions d'années que les dinosaures
aurait des millions d'années alors je
sais pas si tu as regardé les pierrafeu
jurassic park ou n'importe quel autre
film de cul de culture pop n'importe
quel élément de culture populaire à base
de dinosaures les hommes et les
dinosaures cohabitent systématiquement
voilà
donc si il y à de la propagande dans un
sens c'est bien dans le sens biblique
enfin dans le sens qu évidemment ils
vont nous expliquer plus tard parce que
comme je voulais disparu leurs alertes
un adam et eve ont connu les dinosaures
tout ça tout ça je voulais 10 est éculée
un tous eu tout ce qu'on va voir la
maintenance est éculée vous pouvez
d'ores et déjà vous en allez y a plus
rien à voir
y a plus de surprise donc tout ça c est
qu les c est qu les voilà et du cool
la bible nous dit que d'après eux
d'après on serine genesis la bible va
nous dire que les dinosaures et les
hommes ont cohabité et ben je suis
désolé mais l'endoctrinement il va
plutôt dans ce sens là en l'occurrence
dans le sens où les hommes et les
dinosaures ont toujours cohabité parce
que c'est ça qu'on voit dans tous les
éléments de culture populaire donc déjà
ta première phrase tu te l'enroulé tu
lui mets de la vaseline
et puis tu te la mets au fond la vidéo
fait quatre minutes déjà et jean peut
déjà plus bon bref on n'a même pas
commencé les intros pourtant la bible
avec un lien nous fournit un cadre
permettant de créer des fois tu es ici
des sources des fois que les champs
connaîtraient pas ce qu'est la bible
pourtant la bible nous fournit un cadre
permettant de situer les dinosaures sur
une période de quelques milliers
d'années et d'élucider le mystère qui
entoure la chronologie de leur existence
et de leur sort final disons t'aurais
pas un peu copié collé la phrase du
dessus citons de textes de référence à
savoir la genèse et job c'est vrai que
la jeunesse est un texte de référence un
dieu a créé le monde en six jours c'est
complètement une référence moi j'ai
envie de j'ai envie de poser la question
mais dieu créé le monde
enfin dieu créé l'univers en six jours
mais à quel moment est ce que la bible
dit qu'il a arrêté de créer parce que si
ça se trouve
enfin je veux dire on va se mettre dans
un cadre bien créationnistes bien
intelligent design mais si ça se trouve
dieu il n'a pas fini de créer
l'évolution c'est dieu qui continue de
créer point d'interrogation
vous avez deux heures bref moi je veux
bien qu'on me sorte de moment où on lui
dit dieu arrêtez craybas il s'est reposé
le dimanche mais ça veut pas dire qu'il
a pas repris le lundi là
1 1 non bon moi je pose des questions et
eux aussi pose des questions les
dinosaures sont ils un mystère la
réponse est non
nombreux sont ceux qui pensent que les
dinosaures et leur disparition sont
enveloppés d'une brume de mystère si
épaisse qu'il est impossible de
connaître leurs origines et de les
situer dans le temps ou de savoir ce
qu'ils sont devenus
bah c'est quand même dommage pour 200
ans de paléontologie 1 je veux dire
l'origine des dinosaures on a quand même
une grosse idée un le dire ils viennent
d'un groupe dark aux oraux narcose or je
dirais qu'on appelait autrefois les
tecau dompter maintenant les appelle les
dinosaures imhoff bref voilà les
dinosaures imhoff bazzo mais bon voilà
le mystère de leur origine il n'est pas
épais pas si épais que ça en tout cas
les situer dans le temps basset bon
trias jurassique crétacé ces dates et
c'est fait et ce qu'ils sont devenus
météorite dans leur gueule ou oiseaux
voilà donc non ça va le mystère est pas
si épais que ça or les dinosaures ne
sont mystérieux que si l'on accepte une
explication que leur passage sur terre
fondée sur l'évolution nisme encore une
fois pas de mystère au niveau du passage
des dinosaures version évolutionniste
donc nous avions nous arrivons donc nous
avons eu l'endoctrinement des enfants
donc ça c'était la théorie du complot
mais évidemment une bonne théorie du
complot ne ça que je vais y arriver une
bonne théorie du complot ne saurait ne
pas être accompagné d'un bel homme de
paille
donc voici l'homme de paille mesdames et
messieurs le petit épouvantail
évolutionniste qui va faire peur aux
gens
selon les évolutionnistes les dinosaures
se seraient mises a évolué il y à
quelque 235 millions d'années alors je
vais pas m'arrêter sur se serait mis à
évoluer ils se sont mis à faire du vélo
parce qu'elles sont bien évolué aucun
être humain n'aurait d'ailleurs vécu en
même temps que les dinosaures à temps
parce que là je viens de me rendre
compte il ya une source et une source
alors on va ouvrir la petite source fait
péter ta source dans ses numéros 1 qui
est ce qu il cite pour sa jack warner a
way is it quand même deux corners pour
ce sont je pense pas que ja corner et
dit se sont mis à évoluer
par contre aucun être humain n'aurait
d'ailleurs je n'en ai d'ailleurs vécu en
même temps que les dinosaures leur
histoire se retrouveraient consignées
dans des couches de fossiles déposé au
cours des millions d'années or tel était
leur succès
or tel était leur succès en tant que
groupe d'animaux qu'ils auraient enfin
pu dominer la terre
je comprends pas cette phrase toutefois
il y a environ 65 millions d'années un
événement se serait produit qui aurait
tout bouleverser les dinosaures auraient
disparu en effet la plupart des
évolutionnistes pense qu'un cataclysme
tel qu'un impact d'astéroïde les aurait
exterminé par contre d'autres et ils
sont nombreux affirme que certains
dinosaures auraient néanmoins évolué
pour devenir des oiseaux et donc
volerait encore au dessus de nous
aujourd'hui ayant échappé à 6 à
l'extinction bon jusque là excuse moi
mais par rapport aux mystères dont tu
parlais juste au dessus apparemment les
évolutionnistes il ya plus beaucoup de
mystère de leur côté 1
les dinosaures ne sont pas du tout
mystérieux si l'on accepte le récit
biblique qui est totalement différent
mais si tu viens de le dire qu'il y
avait pas de mystère là bas ça va être
l'auront ça va être long un tissu de
contradictions tellement épais que les
trois premiers paragraphes se
contredisent magistralement selon la
bible et c'est là qu'on commence à
rigoler les est-ce qu'on peut lancer la
musique latine
[Musique]
selon la bible les dinosaures sont en
train existence il ya environ 6000 ans
entré en existence ça sent la traduction
kaka est utile ici de quoi la bible là
c'est quoi la référence 3 the lion of
non si j'allais dire tu cites quoi la
bible tu viens de le dire la bible donc
c'est pas selon la bible en fait donc
aux références 3 d'ailleurs j'y pense
mais c'est john morris là je sais pas
qui est john morris et henri maurice
voilà la genèse donc voilà il ya un mec
il ya un mec qui se prend pour dieu je
sais pas voilà selon la bible bah c'est
pas selon la bible apparemment c'est
selon maurice donc selon maurice les
dinosaures sont entrés en existence il
ya 6000 ans en effet dieu a créé les
dinosaures ainsi que les autres animaux
terrestres le sixième jour de la semaine
de la création
or adam et eve fürth également créer le
sixième jour les dinosaures ont vécu en
même temps que les humains ils n'ont pas
été séparés par un gouffre de temps
incommensurable comme dans les pierrafeu
comme le disent les pierrafeu voilà et
puis alors une infographie au cas vous
n'avez pas compris un jour deux jours
trois jours quatre jours six jours début
vers 4000 en bas alors tu viens de dire
si milan tu dis quoi la voilà c'est
pareil tissu de contradictions le tissu
de contradictions continue si milan
quatre mille ans tout va bien tout va
bien vous admirerez notamment alors
cette sélection de dinosaure un crétacé
crétacé ah merde hein du jurassique
donc voilà on te met tous les dinosaures
de la même époque au même endroit on
s'en bat les noix qu'on les retrouve pas
dans les mêmes couches géologiques parce
que je veux dire qu'on accepte les
datations ou pas je veux dire les
datation absolue qui sont faites avec
des médecins de radio chronologique et
autres donc la radioactivité et c'est
comme le carbone 14 mai on n'utilise pas
le carbone 14 pour les dinosaures mais
bref si on n'accepte pas ces dates et
qu'on dit si milan ok admettons
si milan l'invention de l'écriture et du
dinosaure
voilà
le truc c'est qu'on ne retrouve jamais
tyrannosaurus rex
le petit bonhomme en verre là où le
tricératops en même temps que celui là
qui doit être un diplodocus en apothéose
en whatever quoi alors après il ya les
tatillons qui vont me dire c'est à la
mode aux russes ouais bon alors
admettons qu'ils soient au courant qu'il
ya un truc qui s'appelle à la meuse aux
russes les créationnistes et que ce soit
effectivement ça qu'ils ont représenté
en bleu ici admettant mais globalement
les dinosaures au long cours les trouve
quasiment jamais avec les tyrannosaures
quasiment jamais à part justement à la
mosson russe donc je vais dire est ce
que vous niez aussi que du coup il y a
des strates dans lesquels on trouve des
dinosaures à long cou et des strates
dans lesquels on trouve du tyrannosaure
et que ces strates se chevauchent pas
voilà c'est ça ma grande question c'est
est ce que est ce qu'ils en sont à un
point où ils nient l'évidence même que
retrouve pas les mêmes espèces dans les
mêmes couches pareil je pose la question
les dinosaures n'aurait pas pu
disparaître avant l'apparition des
humains car ils n'ont pas précédée ces
derniers or la mort les carnages la
maladie et la souffrance sur le résultat
du péché d'adam quel est le rapport
entre ces deux phrases quelqu'un peut
m'expliquer les dinosaures n'aurait pas
pu disparaître avant l'apparition des
humains car ils n'ont pas précédée ces
derniers or les carnages la maladie la
souffrance sur le résultat du péché
d'adam donc c'est à cause du péché
d'adam que les dinosaures ont disparu en
balayant mystère résolu mystère résolu
donc les dinosaures n'ont pas pu
apparaître avant avant l'apparition des
humains parce qu'ils n'ont pas pu
disparaître non les dinosaures n'ont pas
pu disparaître avant l'apparition des
humains parce que c'est des humains qui
ont causé la mort des dinosaures
ouais c'est beaucoup de responsabilités
sur ces pauvres et paul d'adam quand
même qu'à partir moment ils sont déchus
bout ils deviennent méchants ils
s'entretuent je sais pas qu'est ce qu'il
va nous dire après des représentants de
tous les barres à mine type en hébreu
d'animaux terrestres doté de poumons y
compris du groupe des dinosaures sont
montés à bord de l'arche de noé mais les
autres ont péri dans des conditions
cataclysmique provoqué par le déluge les
res les restes du grand nombre de ces
animaux seront transmis transformant en
fossiles déluge pouf dinosaures
est le tissu de contrat du jeu comprend
même pas la logique des paragraphes les
uns avec les autres
donc les dinosaures n'ont pas pu
disparaître avant l'apparition des
humains à cause du peu parce que c'est
le péché d'adam qui les a tués mais ils
sont montés dans l'arche de noé mais il
met du coup qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ils ont
disparu à cause d' adam mais il était
encore là large de noël je comprends pas
à l'issue du déluge il ya environ quatre
mille trois cents ans les animaux
restants y compris les dinosaures donc
les dinosaures sont bien encore là après
le déluge
va savoir pourquoi sont descendus de
larcher ont vécu dans le monde actuel
avec les humains à cause du péché les
jugements que représente la malédiction
et le déluge ont grandement transformer
la terre en effet le changement
climatique pose diluvien la pénurie de
nourriture la maladie et l'activité
humaine ont contribué à la disparition
de nombreux types d'animaux ainsi les
dinosaures comme beaucoup d'autres
créatures sont progressivement éteint
alors pourquoi ce grand mystère autour
des dinosaures donc
donc pour toi
les dinosaures n'ont pas disparu pendant
le déluge
ils ont disparu après le déluge
progressivement tout ceci étant
parfaitement cohérent avec le fait qu'on
a encore une fois la géologie je veux
dire là on atteint y'a pas d'âge je
donne aucune date ni rien on voit dans
la géologie qui a une couche avec des
dinosaures une couche noire avec de
l'iridium d'origine supposément
météoritique mais même si on admet
qu'elle est pas météoritique mais
d'origine chez pomme du péché d'adam
note donc à une couche avec des
dinosaures une couche noire avec de
l'iridium et une couche sans dinosaures
par dessus le tout et continue je veux
dire y'a pas de discordance et vous
arrivez encore à nous balancer un truc
du genre la disparition des dinosaures a
été progressive
sachant qu'en plus dans les couches dans
lesquels on trouve des dinosaures on
trouve jamais [ __ ] de jamais de faux
cils d'humains
donc même en admettant que le crétacé et
4300 ans
on n'arrive pas vous il ya encore un
millier de trucs que vous nous expliquer
pas là avec votre théorie à deux balles
mais du coup pourquoi ce succès grand
mystère à propos des dinosaures pourquoi
les avis divergent t-il autant mais
divergent pas ils divergent que dans ta
tête
comment peut-il y avoir autant d'avis
aussi radicalement est opposée pour
expliquer les dinosaures pour expliquer
quoi les dinosaures pour expliquer la
disparition des dinosaures pour
expliquer l'existence des dinosaures
pour expliquer quoi les dinosaures
que l'on soit évolutionniste ou que l'on
accepte le récit historique de la bible
le récit historique de la bible
mythologique mythologiques et le mot que
tu cherches cela ne change rien aux
preuves de l'existence des dinosaures en
effet tous les scientifiques disposent
des mêmes données ils se trouvent sur la
même terre et face aux mêmes fossiles au
même être vivant au même univers
oui et dans mon univers à moi dans le
crétacé on trouve pas d'êtres humains et
les dinosaures disparaît soudainement
donc pourquoi est ce que tu vas nous
chercher une explication bibliques ou en
plus tard à une explication
catastrophique tout fait qui s'appelle
le déluge et même celle là tu l'envoies
chier d'encore plus tu pourrais avoir
une explication qui collerait au
registre fossile que même tu la refuse
tu la rejette
pourquoi est-ce que tu as perdu ton
cerveau quelque part je ne sais pas
puisque oui désolé pour la
condescendance à outrance mais l'a
sérieusement à les voir astronomiques
pour la condescendance ils expliquent
beaucoup mieux la condescendance que je
ne le fais au bout d'un moment il ya que
la condescendance qui marche je ne peux
pas continuer à dire ça sans être
condescendant c'est pas possible il ya
trop il ya déjà 1000 contradictions dans
les justes dans la première partie on
n'est même pas un huitième du truc là
regardez ça là on n'est même pas un
huitième du truc j'ai déjà relevé au
moins quatre contradiction en texte
puisque les éléments d'observation sont
les mêmes comment se fait-il que les
explications soient aussi divergentes
bas
parce que tu les invente au fur et à
mesure peut-être tu inventes ces
divergences au fur et à mesure la raison
en est que les scientifiques ne dispose
que du présent ah bon bah c'est dommage
pour ma gueule dit non à en tant que
paléontologues je me sens un peu vexé
[ __ ] non là je suis obligé [ __ ]
étant donné que les fossiles n'existe
que dans le présent mais qu'il tente
toutefois de relier au passé que
s'est-il produit dans le passé se
demande-t-il pour que les dinosaures
fassent leur apparition pour ensuite se
faire exterminer en laissant autant de
vestiges fossilisés de leur passage sur
terre tu te pose la même question alors
pourquoi c'est un problème de
scientifiques plus qu'un problème de
croyants vu que toi en tant que croyant
tu te pose la même question
je comprends pas donc encore une
contradiction de plus le genre de
sciences qui traîne qui traite ce type
de questions se dénomme la science
historique voire des origines et se
distingue de la science opérationnel une
démarche différente qui a permis
d'aboutir par exemple aux ordinateurs
aux produits alimentaires à faible prix
à la conquête de l'espace ou encore à
l'électricité la science des origines
c'est l'étude du passé échappant ainsi à
l'expérimentation direct alors ça je
t'arrête tout de suite
échappant à l'expérimentation direct ça
veut dire ça voudrait dire que les
sciences du passé ou les sciences des
origines comme il les appelle sont des
sciences non prédictive
or on a un épisode qui s'appelle les
siréniens et dans lequel on démontre que
la paléontologie est une science
prédictive donc va te faire [ __ ]
voilà tandis que la science opérationnel
examine le fonctionnement actuel de
l'univers et peut donc être soumis à des
expériences reproductible
vas-y montre moi une expérience
reproductible qui va démontrer la
théorie vas-y vas-y là à boules je
t'attends là puisqu'il est difficile de
reconstruire le passé les spécialistes
des faux cils paléontologue au des
opinions discordantes au sujet des
dinosaures comme jeudi le consensus est
pas si mal établi que ça au final à un
écrivain a dit alors jean-michel
écrivain a dit que la paléontologie
l'étude des fossiles c'est un peu comme
la politique le ton monte vite et il est
facile de tirer des conclusions très
divergentes à partir du même ensemble
d'éléments observé j'aimerais bien
savoir qui a dit ça qu'il va nous sortir
le monique monsieur le monique qui était
monsieur le monique par l'interrogation
à certains éditeurs de scientifique
american bon c'est pas un paléontologue
ça c'est un journaliste de deux
scientifiques américaines donc il peut
avoir des opinions très tranchées sur
sur la paléontologie puisqu'il ne la
pratique pas donc un petit schéma qui
nous montre beaucoup de dinosaures - de
dinosaures bon on est d'accord on est
d'accord au fur et à mesure des
générations visiblement puisque lui ça
deviens vieux et puis lui après ça
devient vieux donc il ya juste un truc
c'est que quand on regarde les courbes
d'évolution de la biodiversité au cours
du temps c'est pas ça qu'on voit alors
je vous renvoie à notre épisode 6
découverte qui invaliderait la théorie
de l'évolution
l'une d'entre elles étant que sachant
que les espèces
on sait on observe aujourd'hui que les
espèces disparaissent comme lady comme
le supposent que les dinosaures ont
disparu au cours du temps voilà comme ça
donc ça veut dire que l'aube c'est ce
qu'on doit observer dans les couches
géologiques un qui ne renie pas il ne
les renie pas il en parle juste au
dessus là donc ce qu'on doit observer
dans les faits dans les couches
géologiques quel que soit leur âge
qu'elle est n des millions d'années où
seulement 4000 ans ou six mille ans
c'est une baisse de la diversité on doit
observer une diminution de la diversité
comme représenté sur ce schéma or ce
qu'on constate c'est tout le contraire
voilà le précambrien c'est ici 0
biodiversité aujourd'hui c'est là et la
diversité
elle augmente et alors les dinosaures il
comme ça commence à la fin du trias donc
à peu près au niveau de ce 4 bon un
petit peu avant en réalité donc les
dinosaures ils apparaissent à peu près
là il ya un petit pic de biodiversité au
milieu du trias une crise d'extinction
et puis après pendant l'époque des
dinosaures la diversité elle ne fait que
augmenté à part ici où on à la
disparition des dinosaures non aviens
mais sinon la diversité c'est
augmentation strike du cambrien jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et même du trias jusqu'à
aujourd'hui donc la biodiversité n'a
fait quasiment que augmenté au cours des
temps géologiques
comment vous expliquer l'origine de
nouvelles espèces sans évolution je vous
attends les gars je vous attends parce
que dans votre schéma vous y'a pas
d'apparition de nouvelles espèces elles
ont été sauvées par l'arche de noé il ya
des espèces qui ont disparu après donc
voilà donc votre donc ça là c'est de la
merde c'est de la merde à voile a
disparu et ensuite le vieux chais pas y
raconte dinosaures ils racontent machin
et au final ça devient dragon je sais
pas on va voir ce qu'ils nous racontent
après ceux ci nous si par sur les
dragons sérieusement ça va commencer à
me gonfler un paléontologue alors un
paléontologue qui croit le récit
biblique livre qui se proclame être la
parole de dieu
alors le livre qui se proclament faut un
livre ne proclame rien les gens proclame
que le livre est la parole de dieu déjà
d'une ensuite la parole de dieu
à quel moment à quel moment
c'est des gens qui prétendent rapporté
la parole de dieu c'est différent la
parole de dieu
si dieu dieu est dieu s'il veut me
parler c'est dans la tête direct parce
que dieu est dieu dieu est omniscient il
n'a pas besoin d'un bouquin pour me
parler il a pas et il a encore moins
besoin de dicter un bouquin à quelqu'un
d'autre pour me parler parce que là
vraiment ça commence à devenir tordu
dans dieu c'est dieu s'il veut parler il
parle il n'a pas besoin d'un bouquin
mais bref
là je parle sur des dérives théologique
à ces personnels ah bah voilà référence
7 qu'il cite là donc la fameuse
référence est voilà dieu qui en a
inspiré les auteurs a toujours existé et
ne ment jamais voilà donc c'est dieu qui
en a inspiré les auteurs voilà donc
c'est dieu qui aurait inspiré quelqu'un
d'autre pour me parler moi ce que je
trouve un peu compliqué pour un dieu
omniscient et omnipotent
mais bon passons donc un paléontologue
blabla la parole biblique tirera des
conclusions différentes de celles d'un
athée qui lui rejette la bible donc un
parole qui croient dans le récit d'un
paléontologue qui croient dans le récit
de la bible j'en connait enfin je
connais des je connais des
paléontologues qui sont globalement
croyants et les paléontologues qui sont
globalement croyants ils parlent pas
évolution de toute façon parce que ça ça
les emmerde forcément mais par contre il
rejette pas la stratigraphie et ça
notamment ce que je viens d'expliquer il
le rejette pas non plus donc voilà ils
font avec leurs contradictions
j'ai envie de dire mais non il va pas
accepter il va pas embrasser le récit de
la bible non par contre il va vivre avec
d'énormes contradictions
le déni volontaire de la parole de dieu
est en effet à l'origine de nombreuses
controverses sur la science historique
beaucoup pensent que la bible n'est
qu'un livre sur la religion ou le salut
pourtant elle traite bien plus de thèmes
que cela en effet la bible c'est non
seulement le manuel d'histoire de
l'univers non non non non c'est
l'histoire du peuple hébreu
la bible c'est pas l'histoire de
l'univers mais aussi la révélation du
destin futur de celui ci elle relate les
événements du commencement des temps les
grandes lignes de l'histoire mais
comment elle peut relater le
commencement des temps puisqu'il y avait
personne parce que dieu il a bien créé
l'homme au sixième jour alors comment on
sait que voilà les cinq premiers jours
du récit de la genèse ils ont pas été
écrit en même temps qu'ils ont eu lieu
plus que les hommes
les auteurs de la bible ne sont n'ont pu
apparaître qu'à partir du sixième jour
donc elle ne relate pas elle rapporte
limites et même en admettant qu'elle
rapporte un récit exactes elles leur
apportent après des milliers d'années
enfin le rapporte des milliers d'années
plus tard les grandes lignes historiques
tels que
arrivé dans le monde du péché et de la
mort la destruction de la surface
entière de la planète par le
l'apparition des différentes langues
à la tour de babel le récit de la venue
des fils de dieu sous forme humaine sa
mort et sa résurrection
ainsi que les nouveaux cieux et la
nouvelle terre futur les dinosaures dans
tout ça
[Musique]
alors j'aime bien cette image parce que
du coup voilà a priori les théories
humaine
c'est un prisme pour voir les dinosaures
mais alors la sainte bible c'est tout
autant à prismes
donc en gros le mec par cette image nous
dit qu'au final ils pensent que c'est ce
côté de l'histoire là est biaisé mais
alors par contre se cotiser de
l'histoire là il nous dit qu'il est tout
aussi biaisés vu que les deux sont
rigoureusement le reflet de l'un de
l'autre et au passage big up pour ned
flanders un net flanders quand même dans
l'histoire biblique
j'aime en fin de compte seuls deux modes
de raisonnement sont possibles par saha
le faux dilemme le faux dilemme
attention là on commence à avoir la
sainte trinité de la sainte trinité du
bullshit on a eu le faux dilemme on a le
faux dilemme
on a eu le on a eu la théorie du complot
et on a eu l'homme de paille
voilà la sainte trinité ou bien le point
de départ le fondement de toute pensée y
compris la biologie l'histoire ou le gnr
ou la géologie c'est la révélation
divine ce qui aboutira donc à une vision
chrétienne du monde ou bien le point de
départ le fondement de toute pensée
c'est la croyance humaines telles que le
récit évolutionniste qui mènera alors
une vision laïque du monde
pendant un moment j'ai cru qu'il allait
dire démoniaque du monde mais bon non à
la limite dans dans le concept où il y
aurait que deux visions possibles du
monde
à la limite ça se tient bien que ce soit
faux la plupart des chrétiens ont subi
un endoctrinement par les médias et les
systèmes éducatifs
la plupart des chrétiens subi un
endoctrinement bas par la bible
peut-être un peu par le fait pas par la
bible pas par la bible elle même par le
dogme qui est autour de la bible par
contre ce qui les a conduits à adopter
une démarche laïque par conséquent ils
ont tendance à appliquer là à la bible
un raisonnement laïque plutôt que
d'utiliser la bible afin de construire
leur pensée pourtant la bible déclare la
connaissance commence par la crainte de
l'éternel mais c'est sympa ça comme
phrase est que le commencement de la
sagesse c'est la crainte de l'éternel
très sympa très très sympa lorsqu une
vision du monde fondée sur l'évolution
nisme constitue non
re point de départ pour l'étude de
l'histoire lorsqu'il n'existe ni témoin
ni témoignage écrit alors même alors je
t'arrête tout de suite yanni témoin
direct ni témoignage écrit dans la bible
non plus les histoires qui sont à la
genèse notamment puisque c'est de la
jeunesse dont il s'agit y a personne qui
était là c'est physiquement impossible
qu'ils aient eu qui que ce soit là
puisque l'homme n'a été créée qu'au 6e
qu'au sixième jour donc ton histoire de
témoignages écrits tu peux te la pareil
tu t'en roules tu mets de la vaseline
pour toi un petit peu de verre pilé 1 du
citron et puis voilà tu te landfill
aussi un alors celle-ci servira de
grille de lecture pour les éléments
d'observation en existence aujourd'hui
houdou d'où l'explication évolutionniste
des dinosaures exposé plus haut oui mais
l'explication évolutionniste des
dinosaures oui mais l'existence des
dinosaures ne dépend pas de l'existence
de la théorie de l'évolution
le
ça n'a rien à voir les deux sont
complètement séparés les uns des autres
d'ailleurs le d'ailleurs le mot
dinosaure a été inventé un para
scientifiques qui ne croyaient pas en
l'évolution et qui s'est toujours opposé
à charles darwin ricciardo wayne et de
deux il a été inventé avant la
publication de l'origine des espèces
donc l'explication évolutionniste des
dinosaures blabla c'est pareil c'est
bullshit ça ne colle pas lorsque par
contre notre point de départ par tout et
pour tout événement historique et la
vision biblique de l'histoire fondée sur
le rapport écrit d'un témoin oculaire
dieu dieu n'a rien écrit dans la bible
il ya aucun passage de la bible qui a
été écrit par dieu ça a été écrit par
des prophètes les gars faut vraiment que
moi je vous explique comment la bible a
été écrit sérieusement alors celle-ci
servira de grille de lecture pour ces
mêmes éléments d'observation d'où
l'explication biblique présenté plus
haut ça fait vraiment mal au cul de lire
des trucs comme ça ça fait mal au cul
parce que je suis pas particulièrement
de non croyants je suis pas
particulièrement apte et en fait donc ça
ça fait mal au cul de lire qu'un mec n'a
même pas compris que la bible avait été
écrit par par des prophètes quoi le dia
va te faire [ __ ]
va te faire [ __ ] je veux dire tu non
seulement tu connais tu comprends rien à
la science mais en plus tu comprends
rien à la bible ou alors c'est encore
pire si tu comprends la science et tu
comprends la bible mais tu te torche le
cul avec ce qui est encore pire c'est
encore pire
déjà déjà j'apprécie pas spécialement la
démarche de vouloir rationaliser la
bible pas ce que ça veut dire qu'en gros
tu crois enfin en gros il faudrait
croire en dieu parce qu'il ya des bonnes
raisons de croire en dieu et ça ça
m'énerve parce que si tu crois en dieu
tu crois en dieu
point final heureux ceux qui croient
sans avoir vu un si tu connais la bible
un peu mec tu dois connaître cette
phrase là voilà heureux ceux qui croient
sans avoir vu ça veut dire que tu crois
en dieu sans preuve de dieu et c'est
encore c'est encore mieux que de croire
en dieu avec des preuves de dieu donc
bref voilà donc oui c'est aussi pour
préciser au passage je suis pas
particulièrement apte et donc là je
m'énerve parce que ce mec dit de la
merde à la fois sur la science mais
aussi sur la bible c'est tout ça pour
contorsionner sa vision du monde
et l'exposer aux gens à la vache deux
sont venus les dinosaures
sans transition d'où sont venus les
dinosaures la bible nous enseigne que
dieu a créé différentes sortes d'animaux
terrestres le sixième jour de la semaine
de la création l oubli par contre de
mentionner les machins de 20 mètres de
long et de plusieurs gigatonnes qui sont
censés avoir marché sur adam et eve
pendant ce temps la buse aaa puisque les
dinosaures sont des animaux terrestres
les divers types de dinosaures ont
forcément été créé ce jour là aussi bah
oui oui mais encore une fois c'est
dommage on a oublié de préciser qu'il y
avait des machins gigantesques et des
trucs avec des dents pas possible de
choisir
c'est marrant ça quand même comme la
bible est passé à côté de ce tout petit
détail
enfin quand comment la genèse est passé
à côté de ce tout petit détail parce que
j'imagine qu'après il va nous dire le
débit à temps et tout ça ce sont des
dinosaures en fait les volumes les
évolutionnistes homme de paille
le retour prétendent que les dinosaures
auraient évolué à partir d'un reptile
quelconque qui lui aurait à son tour
évolué à partir d'amphibiens ouais tu
peux difficilement résumé ça de façon
plus courte mais j'ai envie de dire
pourtant ils ne peuvent citer aucune
forme transitionnelle ah bon ah bon elle
met alors tiktaalik il aux normes us et
les premiers archosaures protée reçu cus
et puis trop su cus et puis ensuite les
premiers dinosaures aux morts
qui sait qu'on peut citer dans les
premiers dinosaures au nord fille assise
des eaux russes par exemple le parquet
ria non il n'y a pas de formes
transitionnelle bien sûr que non non non
non non mais là j'ai même pas aller
chercher sur internet là je vous le fait
que de mémoire
après si je me mets à les chercher sur
internet voilà je vous en trouve une
tetra chier là donc voilà aucune forme
transitionnelle tamer entre les deux
permettant d'étayer leurs arguments les
arbres généalogiques publié dans les
ouvrages évolutionniste prétendent
présente de nombreux types distincts de
dinosaures mais les lignes et mais les
lignes qui les relie à un soi-disant
ancêtre commun ne sont qu'hypothétique
ouais mais ça ça vient de la méthode de
construction de l'arbre ça vient pas
spécialement du registre fossile lui
même la méthode de reconstruction
d'arbre généalogique qui est en fait des
arbres cladistique la technique de
reconstruction d'arbres cladistique par
la clad eastick implique que l'ancêtre
en commun soit hypothétique tu peux pas
m tu peut pas contraindre une analyse
statistique à mettre un véritable
ancêtre commun c'est juste pas possible
c'est pas comme ça que marche une
analyse cladistique voilà donc en fait
le problème de l'analyse cladistique à
la limite et je te rejoins c'est que
même si on avait cet ancêtre commun
eh ben on ne verrait pas dans l'analyse
cladistique en fait ils finiraient
justement comme un type distincts passe
mais ça ça vient plus du problème de
l'analyse cladistique que du problème du
registre fossile en lui-même connard ces
lignes apparaissent d'ailleurs en
pointillés justement parce qu'elles ne
sont appuyées par aucune preuve sous
forme fossiles non ça c'est parce que tu
regardes les des vieilles publications
sur les lignes en pointillés c'est juste
les vieilles publication concrètement
les évolutionnistes sont tout simplement
incapables de prouver leur croyance
selon laquelle les dinosaures aurait eu
un nom dinosaures comme ancêtre en
commun un nom un nom dinosaures comme
ancêtre pardon bah si jamais vous dire
par keyria si les eaux russes voilà
c'est l'ancêtre l'ancêtre des
inodore c'était un dinosaure imhof voilà
on appelle ça un dinosaure imhoff donc
allé voir dès que des analystes la
distique des dinosaures voilà donc
dinosaures il ya club distique voilà
est-ce que j'ai bien écrit que la
justice non j'ai mal écrit cladistique
j'ai même mal écrit dinosaures yalil ans
je suis quand même balèze mallet fois et
puis vous prenez un arbre qui n'est pas
un arbre justement
tout graphique comme ça mais un arbre
qui tirait d'une véritable publications
scientifiques
donc on devrait en trouver un quelque
part voilà ici par exemple
et puis voilà donc voilà ça c'est tiré
de saïan visiblement et puis bah ici
vous avez donc les dinosaures dinosauria
est ici vous avez les dinosaures
immortal vous avez les si les ori des
dons si les eaux russes les la gerbe et
idées voilà donc ici vous avez des trucs
à la base des dinosaures qui vivaient
avant les dinosaures ou en même temps
que les tous premiers dinosaures et qui
sont de très bons candidats comme groupe
ancêtres des dinosaures je vais dire il
suffit de se référer à la bonne biblio
évidemment si tu regardes des trucs avec
des arbres en pointillés qui date de
mathusalem évidemment ça va pas marcher
a pas marché mais si tu regardes la
bonne littérature moi ça me prend 40
secondes le lire pour trouver cet arbre
là ça m'a pris 40 secondes sur google
images d'un pourquoi pourquoi toi tu
fais pas ces efforts là à quoi
ressemblaient les dinosaures
alors je pense qu'on s'éloigne un peu du
sujet mais fait voir ce que tu as à dire
il est rare qu'un scientifique puisse
des terrains à dinosaures avec toute sa
chair intacte oui bah merci merci
captain obvious et même lorsqu'il
retrouve ceci étant dit ceci étant dit
ceci étant dit on à bourg et aux pétales
tas je crois que c'est son petit nom
boréale hop lta pardon boréale hop lta
bon c'est pas un dinosaure avec toute la
viande mais ça en est pas loin quand
même hein et puis on a les mots me dan
rose or aussi la momie d'adp rose or
donc à droz or mamie et il me semble que
son petit surnom c'est leonardo oui son
petit surnom c'est leonardo
alors leonardo il est ce qu'il ya une
belle photo quelque part ça voilà donc
leonardo bon c'est une momie qui a été
fossilisé donc évidemment il n'y a pas
toute la viande dessus mais on voit bien
qu'ils restent de la peau et tout donc
bon on déterre pas des trucs entier mais
on déterre quand même des trucs pas mal
et même lorsqu'il retrouve tous les os
il dispose de moins de 40 % de l'animal
pour en deviner l'apparence original ah
oui bah c'est ce qui me fait penser
d'ailleurs microraptor non je suis
désolé je vais j'ai oublié mais
évidemment il ya aussi le fossile s'il
te plaît le fossile enfin les fossiles
puisqu'il y en a plusieurs
voilà microraptor excuse-moi fossiles à
40% vous avez dit un fossile à 40%
non non je suis désolé vous devez vous
trompez de disciplines scientifiques oui
oui allez vous faire [ __ ]
oui c'est ça en effet ces zones ne
révèle pas par exemple la couleur de
l'animal est alors la couleur de
l'animal donc voilà après une petite
recherche sur la page stop science j'ai
fini par retrouver cette publication où
on parle justement de la façon dont on
reconstitue la couleur des dinosaures à
partir du moment où évidemment les
plumes sont conservés comme sur ce
caillou zhuji voilà donc si on peut
aussi faire ça même si l'on a découvert
quelques impressions de pau fossilisés
qui nous permettent d'en établir le
grain or étant donné la diversité des
couleurs observé chez les reptiles
vivants aujourd'hui il est possible
qu'il est qu'il est exigé une grande
variété de qu'il est et qu'il ait existé
pardon une grande variété de couleurs de
grain de peau etc
chez les dinosaures aussi oui mais on a
un peu con on a un peu restreint quand
même le le champ des possibles d'autre
part lorsque ils reconstruisent des
dinosaures à partir de vestiges osseux
les scientifiques ont recours à des
suppositions de tout genre et sont
souvent en désaccord les uns avec les
autres par exemple à débat fait rage
encore sur la question de si les
dinosaures étaient des animaux à sang
chaud ou à sang froid
alors certes oui mais ça n'influe pas
tellement sur la représentation elle
même
il est même difficile de savoir le sexe
d'un dinosaure à partir de ces eaux
oui je suis d'accord avec cette
affirmation
en effet les spéculations joue un rôle
important dans ce genre de questions bah
oui mais enfin tu va m'expliquer en quoi
tu veux résoudre le problème enfin les
scientifiques se trompe parfois dans
leurs constitutions et doivent les
corriger lorsque d'autres ossements sont
découverts par exemple on ne retrouve
plus on ne retrouve plus le fameux
brontosaure à et dictionnaires les plus
récents car celui ci celui qu'il avait
découvert avait placé la mauvaise tête
sur un dinosaure déjà nommés à savoir la
pâte aux orres way ceci dit brontosaure
est revenu un peu vu que même si on n'a
pas même si on n'avait pas le crâne ans
il est quand même différent son
squelette post crânien est quand même
différent de celui de la patte au sort
donc brontosaure a été ressuscité depuis
ressuscité ressuscité bon et alors
qu'antti à quoi ressemblaient les
dinosaures baffe à la limite on a une
meilleure on a une bien meilleure idée
que ce dont il que ce qu'il prétend de
ce à quoi ressemblaient les dinosaures
mais bon ou tu vas avec ça est-ce que tu
essaies de diaboliser scientifique bout
les scientifiques utilisent la
spéculation pour faire des images
bah ouais mais en soit nous on étudie
les eaux donc c'est léo qui nous
intéresse nous on fait des belles images
c'est surtout pour les musées et le
public 1
nous on s'en sert pas vraiment des
belles images ont fait pas de science
basée sur les images quoi qui a
découvert les dinosaures aa les ouvrages
laïque vous diront que la première
découverte de ce qui serait par la suite
appelé dinosaures eu lieu en 1677
lorsque le docteur robert pilotte trouva
les autres tellement énorme qu'il
pensait qu'ils appartenaient à un
éléphant gigantesque voire même à un
humain géant tiens pour une fois un
créationniste est pas trop mal
renseignés d'après la tradition 1822
pendant que qu'elle se promenait sur une
petite route de la campagne du sussex en
angleterre une certaine marie anne
martel aurait trouvé une pierre qui est
un seul et au soleil lorsqu'elle a
montré à son mari médecin et
collectionneur de fossiles le docteur
mentait l'aurez remarqué qu'elle
contenait une dent ressemblant à celle
d'un reptile moderne sauf qu'elle était
bien plus grande
il conclut qu'elle provenait d'un
quelconque reptiles disparu herbivores
dont les dents ressembler à celle de
l'iguane puis en 1825 il appela le
propriétaire de 2,7 dans iguanodon dans
d'iguane ce fut précisément le docteur
mantel qu'ils allaient commencer à
populariser à populariser la notion de
l'ère des reptiles cependant d'un point
de vue biblique ces découvertes ne
constituent pas des ne constituent que
des redécouvertes car ce fut adam qui
découvrit les dinosaures lorsqu'il est
observée pour la première fois et on a
évidemment un rapport écrit de tout ça
évidemment la bible nous dit texto adam
a vu des dinosaures ou la non non non
non et non à quelle époque vives et les
dinosaures voilà donc en transition sur
un autre paragraphe on ne nous dira pas
on ne nous citera pas ce fameux passage
de la bible ou adam dit oh [ __ ] ça un
dinosaure genèse paragraphe 8
je ne sais pas non tu quittes à aller
quelque part tu veux bien nous emmener
quelque part avec ce paragraphe non bon
ben non alors à quelle époque vivaient
les dinosaures sans transition une fois
de plus à quelle époque vives et les
dinosaures les évoluent les
évolutionnistes prétendent que les
dinosaures vivaient il ya des millions
d'années
oihana mais il ne faut pas oublier que
lorsqu ils déterrent un os de dinosaures
il n'ya pas d'étiquette collée dessus
indiquant la date
bah non c'est pour ça qu'on utilise la
radio chronologie en effet
l'évolutionnisme devrait obtenir non
mais attends et c'est un reportage
animalier où coulent l'évolutionnisme à
la recherche de dinosaures se cache en
embuscade la meo en effet
l'évolutionnisme doit obtenir sa date
par des méthodes indirectes de datation
que d'autres scientifiques remettent
d'ailleurs en question or de nombreux
éléments de preuve permettent de d2
démentir ces millions d'années référence
12 alors qu'ils référencent 2 encore
maurice abbas a alors le même maurice
qui se prenait pour dieu paragraphes
suivants l'ain au paragraphe précédent
donc maurice qui se prend pour dieu m'a
dit non mais la datation ça marche pas
en fait je suis pas expert du tout mais
ça marche pas dieu nous dit enfin c'est
pas comme si on utilisait plein de
méthodes de datation en même temps tu
vois et on n'en utilise pas qu'une de
méthodes de datation
différentes méthodes de radio
chronologie il ya aussi les inversions
de champs magnétiques les zircon enfin
bref il ya quand même un paquet de
manière de dater les fossiles et puis on
les dates pas qu'à un seul endroit aussi
c'est à dire que si on retrouve le un
fossile très similaire un endroit du
globe et à l'autre dans des couches très
différentes on va adapter les couches
très différentes et on a le même âge
didon comme c'est curieux mais non mais
tout ça c'est un complot bien sûr dieu
nous dit il quand est-ce qu'il a créé le
tyrannosaure rex on dirait un bébé qui
parle nombreux sont ceux qui diraient
que non et c'est vrai ils ont raison
pourtant la bible déclare que dieu créa
toute chose en six jours ordinaires
or il créa les animaux terrestres dont
les dinosaures le sixième jour oui mais
moi je veux que tu me cites mois le
passage de la jeunesse où il ya écrit
qu'il a créé des vrais petits le groupe
15 met là 2,5 mètres de large
comme dans comme dans la vidéo de
simples 2 du top du top man quand est-ce
qu'il a créé des dinosaures de 5 mètres
de large ce qui nous donne une date
d'environ 6000 ans à savoir la date
approximative de la création obtenu par
cumulation des années précisé dans la
bible sur ce 13 encore maurice encore
maurice oui parce que encore une fois la
bible ne dis pas qu'elle est la bible ne
dis pas que la terre assimilant c'est
des mecs qui prennent la bible et qui
font des calculs ultra spéculatifs à
partir de la bible donc en l'occurrence
ils prennent le temps de génération
entre chaque protagoniste de la bible
sachant qu'il ya des protagonistes qui
vivent environ 600 ans tu vois c'est
quand même réaliste un faut bien savoir
donc non la bible elle même ne dit pas
le monde a été créé il ya 6000 ans c'est
des gens qui prennent la bible et qui
disent que le monde a été créé à 6000
ans et d'ailleurs nous n'irons pas dans
la controverse à ce niveau là parce
qu'il ya quand même des gens qui eux il
ya quand même beaucoup de gens qui se
sont tentés à l'expérience et ont abouti
à des résultats qui sont radicalement
différents mais ça on ne va pas en
parler ici nos oignons par conséquent
puisque t-rex était un animal terrestre
et que dieu créa tous les animaux
terrestres
le sixième jour alors dieu créa t-rex ce
même jour cet argument ne se mord pas là
que jamais jamais de la vie cet argument
ne se mord la queue
non non non par contre nous on trouve
des fossiles de t-rex des vrais seins
pas des trucs qu'on dit que dieu l'a
écrit dans la bible non non non on
trouve des fossiles des vrais ont des
dates on en trouve partout dans plein
d'endroits différents dans différentes
couches les différentes couches nous
donne le même âge mais non c'est la
bible qui dit que tout a été créé et
donc forcément il y avait tiré kz2 dans
qui a raison mais bien sûr pas soyons
enfin c'est pas c'est pas question de
qui a raison pas c'est qui est le
meilleur argument quoi je vais dire
voilà maintenant la bible dit que tout a
été créé donc dans tout il ya
tyrannosaure puis voilà je veux dire
c'est tout ça marche ça marche ça marche
d'autre part la bible nous enseigne
qu'avant l'arrivée du péché il n'y avait
ni mort ni effusion de sang ni maladie
ni souffrance alors notre 14
ah bah non c'est pas la bible c'est
monsieur ce temps beau qui nous dit ça
c'est pas la bible
encore une fois or si l'on veut adopter
une approche cohérente pour la lecture
de l'ensemble de la bible à savoir de la
jeunesse jusqu'à l'apocalypse en
interprétant les écritures par les
écritures alors on est contre admettre
que la mort et l'effusion de sang des
hommes comme des animaux ne sont
intervenus qu'après le péché d'adam oui
encore une fois je ne dis pas que ceci
est un argument circulaire mais ceci est
un argument circulaire la bible à raison
donc la bible a raison cqfd
si la bible a raison alors les et
dinosaures sont forcément apparu ont
forcément disparu après l'apparition de
l'homme
donc la bible a raison tiens prends ça
athéistes d'ailleurs le premier animal
est mort lorsque dieu versa le sens de
cette bête dans le jardin d'éden et
habille à adam et eve abat donc la mort
et la souffrance existait alors à vendre
la jeunesse serait pleine de
contradictions
oh mon dieu quelle découverte soit dit
en passant qu'il s'agissait là d'un
symbole d'expiration du péché
préfigurant ainsi le sang du christ qui
devaient être versés pour nous il est
donc impossible qu'il ait pu exister
avant l'avènement du péché des ossements
d'animaux morts sans que cela porte
atteinte au sens même de l'évangile bon
bah c'est le même argument circulaire et
et qui ce contreur et qui contredit
cette phrase là voilà pourquoi dieu
n'aurait pas fait dépôt pour attend
pourquoi pourquoi dieu n'aurait pas
habiter adam habillé adam et eve de peau
de dinosaures et c'est comme ça qu'ils
auraient disparu un prouve moi que j'ai
tort
vas-y vas-y vas-y prouve moi que j'ai
tort la boule à boules les arguments par
conséquent les dinosaures ont dû mourir
après l'avènement du péché dans le monde
et non pas avant sauf s'il s'en sont
fait dépôt ainsi il est impossible que
les ossements de dinosaures puisse
remonter à des millions d'années puisque
cela ne fait que quelques milliers
d'années caden marché sur la terre mais
oui évidemment la bible à raison donc la
bible à raison à la bible
mentionne-t-elle des dinosaures ouais
est-ce qu'on va arrêter d'avoir que des
arguments circulaire s'il vous plaît si
les humains avaient vu des dinosaures il
serait logique de supposer que les
textes anciens tels que la bible il
fasse allusion
or la bible de genève fut publié en 1560
et d'après certains puisque le mot
dinosaures ne figure ni dans cette
version ni dans d'autres traductions la
bible des les mentionne donc pas esquive
esquif de l'enfer le niveau matrix ce
niveau-là à l' esquive de l'enfer oui
mais bon tu aurais pu appeler sa gros
reptile ou gros oiseaux
je veux dire il doit bien exister des
mots enfin je veux dire c'est vraiment
l' esquive bas de gamme
si l'homme a fréquenté le diplodocus
il devait y avoir un mot pour ça même si
le mot n'était pas diplodocus forcément
mais je sais tu vas tu vas en venir au
léviathan et tout ça je le sais déjà je
le sais déjà c'est pas la peine de
s'énerver
c'est bon donc là et une petite
infographie une petite infographie pour
bien expliquer aux tbi
quand même que si on n'avait pas inventé
le mot dinosaures ce n'était pas un
dinosaure
pourtant il fallut attendre en 1841 pour
que le mot dinosaures soit inventé
lorsqu'il a examiné l'exaucement dewind
mégawatheure owen tintintin célèbre
anatomiste britannique et premier
conservateur du british museum
d'ailleurs fervent anti darwiniste s'est
rendu compte qu'il s'agissait et en plus
il le sait en plus il le sait rappelez
vous de ce que j'ai dit au tout début la
revenez en arrière dans la vidéo
rappelez vous de ce que j'ai dit tout au
début en plus ce connard le sait le mec
le sait que le mot dinosaures il a été
inventé par un anti darwiniste qu'il est
il est encore là à dire le complot des
dinosaures gnagnagna le complot des
dinosaures c'est darwiniste c'est pour
défendre que la terre à des millions
d'années il sait que le mot dinosaure a
été inventé par un anti darwiniste
fumier fumier de fumier ah non mais
sérieusement est-ce que c'est possible
d'être plus malhonnêtes que ça veut dire
moi je suis un connard condescendant
mais lui c'est vraiment une malhonnêteté
intellectuelle incroyable zen zen à 11
on s'est rendu compte qu'il s'agissait
d'un groupe si particulier de reptiles
dans singulier pardon de reptiles non
répertorié non encore répertoriés ces
traductions de fou c'est lui qui a
élaboré le terme dinosaures à partir du
grec pour les arts terrible il est donc
normal que le mot dinosaures
n'apparaissent pas dans la bible de
genève qu'il n'existait pas encore à
l'époque de cette traduction existe et
il un terme pour dinosaures dans le
monde entier on raconte des légendes de
dragon ah bah oui on rencontre des
légendes de dragons et on en parle
beaucoup dans ce top science des dragons
oui on a une petite vidéo qui parle de
dragon de stop science up stop science
dragon et vous allez voir que le mot
dragon n'a absolument rien à voir avec
le mot dinosaures enfin vous allez voir
que le mythe des dragons n'a absolument
rien à voir avec le mythe des dinosaures
la plupart des mythes de dragon bah en
fait c'est de la propagande chrétienne
voilà le dragon et enlacer ce qu'on
explique à peu près tout ça non voilà
c'est ce qu'on explique à ce niveau là
dans la vidéo en gros le mythe du dragon
c'est là c'est juste la carnation du mal
en fait
et systématiquement vous avez un saint
qui arrivent pour sauver le drame pour
sauver le village menacé par le dragon
c'est à dire menacé par le mal et
convertir tout le monde au catholicisme
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on 20 la
bête
le serpent je rappelle le serpent le
serpent c'est le mal
rappelez-vous dans la religion
chrétienne
donc tu es légende de dragon c'est
pareil c'est le dragon c'est le
l'incarnation du mal si vous préférez ça
n'a rien à voir avec les inodore rien du
tout et on a fait toute une vidéo de 15
minutes pour vous démontrer ça donc
c'est pareil allez voir la vidéo
or de nombreuses descriptions de dragon
correspondent donc à rester
caractéristiques particulières des
dinosaures notamment le fait qu'ils
avaient des ailes c'est bien connu
tyrannosaure avait des ailes diplodocus
savaient voler si si monsieur ho oui et
cracher du feu cracher du feu aussi ça
c'est pas mal s'agit-il de rencontres
avec des créatures qui porte aujourd'hui
ce nom alors je change je fais silence
aussi du fait que est-ce que c'est dans
la bible qu'on parle de dragon on va
voir dans la suite tout le monde tout
comme les légendes de déluge fondée sur
le vrai déluge mondiale le déluge de noé
celle des dragons sont peut-être
inspirés par des rencontres de vrais
animaux que nous appelons aujourd'hui
dinosaures un grand nombre des
descriptions de ces dragons terrestre
concorde avec ce que nous savons des
dinosaures à la bible déclare dans la
jeunesse ça y est là le moment tant
attendu le moment la jeunesse parle de
dinosaures dieu créa les grands poissons
tous les animaux vivant capable de se
déplacer l'eau en plus là selon leur
espèce
selon leur espèce et c'est pas des
dinosaures sa 1 1 1
franchement tu vois pas la description
la dinosaures là ça transparaît pas dans
ceux est c'est quand même une phrase qui
a été sélectionné dans la bible afin de
remplir la fonction de nous faire croire
que la bible parle de dinosaures donc le
mec
ils savaient ce qu'ils faisaient quand
il a sélectionné cette phrase un dieu
créa les grands poissons et les grands
poissons d'après lui or le mot hébreu
qui correspond dans ce contexte à grands
poissons et traduit ailleurs comme
dragon le et bretagne ainsi dans le
premier chapitre de la bible il se peut
que dieu fasse allusion aux énormes
dragon de la mer animaux marins de type
dinosaures qu'il avait créé
sauf que
il n'y avait pas de dinosaures dans
l'eau et 2,2 et 2,2 il ya un truc qui
s'appelle des baleines un truc qui
s'appelle des baleines et qui ressemble
vachement à des grands poissons alors
tana en hébreu vas-y fais moi rêver
fais moi rêver google alors tanins
apparemment ça veut dire monstre tanning
moi je ne sais pas encyclopaedia
universalis tiens ça
tallinn est ce que tu l'aurais pas en
français cette page non bon ben alors ta
nine hébreu arabi kutan août hounhanou
était un monstre marin dans les
religions cananéenne phénicienne et dans
la mythologie et breuses voilà c'est un
monstre des mers donc la bonne
traduction de thann a visiblement ces
monstres des mers ont vérifié avec
encyclopaedia universalis voilà que bien
mythique les adducteurs de la version
des 70 ont un conte aussi les bretonnes
un serpent que leviathan léviathan donc
la nasa veut aussi dire serpent
léviathan dragon donc c'est un dragon
mais dans le genre serpentiforme donc ça
va pas non plus grand chose à voir avec
donc ça va pas non plus grand chose à
voir avec un dinosaure
un dragon serpentiforme bof
1 encore une fois tyrannosaur serpent
même chose pareille mais non mais non
mais tu sais quand on quand on veut
faire entrer des trucs au chausse pied
on balance le chausse pied met en
balance du gros chausse-pied quoi il se
peut que dieu non il se peut que la
personne qui a écrit la genèse 1 fasse
allusion aux énormes dragon de la mer
que ne sont pas les dinosaures
merci donc déjà ce passage-là de la
bible magnifiquement sélectionner un
montre que les hébreux était capable de
voir des baleines
ben voilà d'autres passages de la bible
par également de dragon vivant dans la
mer donc toujours pas de dinosaures
ah mais oui mais je sais les tatillons
vont dire c'étaient les reptiles marins
mais il y en a aucun qui ressemblait à
un serpent aucun pas aussi lé limite les
mosasaures il avait les on pense
aujourd'hui que les mozart était
vaguement apparentés aux serpents mais a
semblé plus quand même à des warrants
cas les serpents donc c'était plus des
gros varan marin que des serpents
donc non ça qualifie toujours pas donc
les dragon des mers qui ne peuvent pas
par définition est des dinosaures dragon
sous les eaux psaume il tuera le dragon
qui est dans la mer et sailly or si le
mot dinosaures désigne stricto sensu des
animaux terrestres
merci de le rappeler les reptiles marins
et volants sont souvent assimilés aux
dinosaures
surtout quand ça arrange les
créationnistes il est donc possible que
la catégorie des dragons marin renfermer
les animaux de type dinosaures tels que
les mosasaures c'est c'est eh oui oui
mais encore une fois c'est essaye de
démontrer quoi que tu n'y connais rien
ou que les dinosaures sont dans la bible
voilà si on fait des gros raccourci
crasseux alors j'ai raison bah oui mais
il faut faire des gros à cons sic
crasseux donc t'as pas raison fin du
couple est ciao bye job 41 décrit un
énorme animal vivant dans la mer le
léviathan qui crachait même du feu et ça
c'est scientifique les mecs
cette bête ressembler peut-être au super
croco de 12 mètres le sarcosuchus
imperator ou encore au lieu que l'eurusd
de va
5 m ou à rien parce que c'est un animal
qui crachait du feu
pokémon uns parlent d'un animal qui
s'appelle les viator et qui crachait des
et qui crachait des dracs orages
peut-être que c'était un sarcosuchus ou
un lieu plus redon ouais ou peut-être
qu'on l'a juste inventé à qui c'est la
bible mentionne également le serpent
volant et oui le serpent volant il
pourrait s'agir d'un ptérodactyle que
l'on nomme communément dinosaures volant
tels que l'opéra de dans leur en faire
un coup ou encore en it ok russe oui
mais encore une fois les ptérodactyles
ne sont pas des dinosaures volant et
encore moins des serpents volant or les
ronces et même maintenant que les
ptérodactyles comme tu dis été
recouverts de plumes
là ça a été ça a été montré il ya pas
longtemps dans cet article voilà dans
cet article les télés tégument complexe
des ptérosaures qui ressemble à des
plumes et qui ont tout et qui ont toutes
les caractéristiques des plumes et donc
les ça veut dire que les ptérosaures
voilà en l'occurrence le ptérosaure qui
a été étudié pour cette étude
ressemblait plutôt à ça vas-y cherche le
serpent la cherche le serpent mec ça
c'est la représentation la plus précise
qu'on aide un ptérosaure bon alors celui
là en l'occurrence c'est un c'est une
espèce particulière qui appartient la
famille des agneaux gagne à ty qui était
une famille avec un museau très court
mais en gros un ptérodactyle ça devait
ressembler à ça avec un museau long et
pointue donc ça c'est pas un serpent
volant voilà ça ne qualifie pas la
catégorie des serpents volant suivant et
qui crache pas de feu peu après le
déluge dieu montrer à un certain job sa
grandeur en tant que créateur en lui en
lui rappelant l'animal terrestre le plus
énorme de sa création voit donc le
béhémoth que j'ai fait aussi bien que
toi
ils mangent l'herbe comme le boeuf voit
donc sa force et dans ses flancs et sa
vigueur dans les muscles son ventre il
ré dit ça que semblable aux cèdres les
tendons de ses hanches sont enlacés
c'est au son des tubes des reins ses
membres sont des sons comme des barres
de fer
il est le chef-d'oeuvre de dieu son
créateur lui a donné son épée ouais bah
je sais pas pour vous mais moi j'y vois
juste la description d'asnières beevor
quelconque je veux dire voilà c'est un
herbivore il a des gros flanc il a des
gros muscles alors peut-être le seul
truc que je veux bien vous accorder sur
ce coup là il re edit ça que semblable
aux cèdres
donc effectivement il n'ya pas beaucoup
d'herbivores qui ont une grosse que ça
semble exclure l'éléphant les
hippopotames les rhino d'emblée donc
effectivement il re edit ça que
semblable aux cèdres
c'est un élément intéressant de cette
description
c'est un élément incongru inattendu mais
est-ce que ça suffit vraiment à dire que
c'était un dinosaure est ce que c'est
vraiment là dessus que vous allez partir
pour nous dire que cette description
décrire dinosaures l'a sérieusement je
veux dire comment dire est ce que le
fait que la que soient semblables aux
cèdres est vraiment votre seul argument
pour dire que cette description est une
description de dinosaure herbivore ce
que bon là quand même une description de
dinosaures
beevor ça aurait quand même du mal à ne
pas passer par sa tête ridiculeusement
petit au bout d'un coup ridiculeusement
long ou bien mazette ces trois cornes
sur sa tronche c'est énorme
ou bien chez pas moins sept rangées de
plaques sur son dos et ses épines sur le
bout de sa queue semblable aux cèdres là
éventuellement tu peux me parler de ça
que semblable aux cèdres
mais là sérieusement je veux dire est ce
qu'une description d'un dinosaure
herbivore gérant seraient passés à côté
genre des trucs les plus évidents pour
au final nous parler à au fait il a une
grosse que voilà non je pose la question
je pose la question
donc bon l'expression chef-d'oeuvre de
dieu donne à supposer qu'il s'agissait
de l'animal terrestre le plus grand que
dieu ait créé quel type d'animal était
donc le béhémoth alors le chef-d'oeuvre
de dieu je sais pas ce qu'est le
chef-d'oeuvre de dieu exactement par
contre je peux te dire une chose c'est
que si c'est le chef-d'oeuvre de dieu
par définition ça doit pas être une
espèce éteinte
parce que si le chef-d'oeuvre de dieu
est une espèce qui n'était pas adapté
bah c'est chiant je le répète si le
chef-d'oeuvre de dieu était une espèce
qui n'était pas adapté à l'environnement
que dieu a créé c'est chiant c'est très
chiant
donc ça peut pas être un dinosaure par
définition par définition les dinosaures
ayant disparu ça veut dire qu'il n'était
pas adapté à l'environnement de dieu et
s'il n'était pas adapté à
l'environnement de dieu ça risque pas
d'être les chefs-d'oeuvre de dieu donc
qu'est la type d'animal était donc le
béhémoth certainement pas un dinosaure
très cher enfin c'est bizarre quand même
si c'est donc le chef-d'oeuvre de dieu
pourquoi on ne décrit pas plus souvent
pourquoi pourquoi il n'a pas un rôle
plus important dans la bible dans cette
expression chef-d'oeuvre de dieu elle
est très parlante ont contraire aller
elle nous dit beaucoup de choses sur
quel était le type d'animal en tout cas
elle est de nous dit beaucoup de choses
sur ce que n'était pas le béhémoth ne
sachant pas très bien de quel animal il
s'agit des traducteur de la bible se
sont contentés de d'une simple
translittération du mot hébreu behemoth
par exemple dans la version d'os serval
des cités plus haut et plusieurs
traductions anglaise entre autres
toutefois de nombreux commentaires
bibliques et notes de bas de pages
fournies dans des différentes éditions
de la bible spéculent que le béhémoth
est peut-être un hippopotame ou un
éléphant certaines versions de la bible
vont jusqu'à traduire bmod de cette
manière or à part le fait que ni
l'éléphant ni l'hippopotame ni neil
animal terrestre le plus grand de la
création certains dinosaures les dépasse
et de loin
cette supposition n'a aucun sens puisque
la queue du behemoth est comparé à un
cèdre à savoir un grand arbre peut-être
que c'était que la couleur du coup non
je ne sais pas un je demande donc à bah
voilà oui c'est exactement ça donc c'est
tout l'argument tient sur la queue voilà
la queue est le seul argument qu'ils ont
pour dire que c'était une description de
dinosaures en effet la petite que de
l'éléphant ne ressemble en rien à un
cèdre et celle de l'ipo potable ne
ressemble d'ailleurs un simple repli de
pau il est donc évident que ni
l'éléphant ni l'hippopotame ne pourrait
être le béhémoth aucun animal vivant
n'arrive à la cheville de cette créature
par contre le béhémoth ressemble
énormément un brachiosaure l'un des plus
grands dinosaures à part qu'on a
négligemment oublié de préciser qu'il
avait une toute petite est au bout d'un
énorme et long cou voilà de médecine ont
ça colle parfaitement avec la
description d'un brachiosaures on a
juste oublié de dire que c'était on a
juste oublié de décrire genre le truc le
plus important là pour l'éléphant pour
le coup je suis d'accord aussi qu' on
oublie de décrire la tromper les
défenses enfin je veux dire de 7,17
description elle est magnifique parce
qu'elle te donne le seul indice qui ne
sert à rien le seul indice utile et
finalement lundi ce qui te sert le plus
à rien parce que ça colle
à tout et à rien donc au final on s'en
fout c'est la tête qu'il fallait décrire
base et des arguments sur la que ça sert
à rien il a une queue et c'est pas mal
et moi j'aime bien d'autres d'autres
textes anciens mentionne-t-il les
dinosaures
la réponse est probablement oui
probablement non mais de toute façon ce
sera jamais assez clair pour qu'on le
comprenne
le documentaire the great dinosaur
mystery référence 23 j'aimerais bien
savoir qui a fait 2 pl est bon bah si
vous avez lu vous savez pourquoi je me
marre voilà pis taylor the great
dinosaur mystery film fort kreis sanaa
ça n'a rien à voir avec de la propagande
non pas du tout on utilise un film de
propagande créationnistes pour comme
argument créationnistes je veux dire
vrai on reste dans le dinosaure de
dinosaures qui se mord la queue car j'ai
envie de dire l'expression le dinosaure
qui se mord la queue
donc voilà on reste dans notre
dinosaures qui se mord la queue
le wpt est donc dans le documentaire
les créationnistes pour les
créationnistes présente plusieurs récits
de dragon une épopée sur meriem datant
d'au moins deux mille ans avant
jésus-christ clair raconte l'exploit
d'un héros nommé gilles gamme edge qui
lorsqu'il sortit abattre des cèdres dans
la forêt lointaine des cèdres encore
tomba sur un énorme dragon féroce qu'il
tua est ramenée à la tête comme trophée
allez vous décrire la tête que du dragon
qui a tué gilles kammesh n'ont jamais de
la vie
lorsqu'alexandre legrand dans vers 330
avant jésus-christ surnommé entrèrent en
inde ils découvrirent que les indiens
adorait d'énormes reptiles sifflant
qu'il gardait dans des grottes
alors qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'il ya comme
reptiles qui sifflent et qui peut
atteindre des grandes tailles le mystère
reste entier un reptile qui sifflent
évidemment je vais pas aller vérifier
toutes ces sources cela parce que ça
prendrait des plombes d'aller relire
toute l'épopée de gilgamesh ça prendrait
des plombes d'aller chez quai d'où sort
cette histoire d'alexandre le grand
bizarrement vous noterez que donc la
seule source qu'on a c'est the great
dinosaur mystery un là bizarrement il
est beaucoup moins pressés de nous citer
des sources 1
mais bon voilà très facilement donc
gilles gamme edge tu as un dragon bah
ouais fort bien des histoires de dragons
comme jeudi les histoires de dragon
c'est comme tout le reste c'est comme
les histoires de géant
c'est comme les trous du cul tout le
monde en a une voilà la chine est
renommée pour ses récits de dragon qui
occupe d'ailleurs une place importante
dans les motifs de faïence des broderies
et des sculptures de ce pays oui ah oui
là la chine est peut-être le seul
endroit où d'ailleurs les fossiles sont
directement reliés au mythe des dragons
le truc c'est que les dragons en
l'occurrence en chine c'est à peu près
tous les fossiles qu'ils appellent des
dragons pas seulement les fossiles de
dinosaures donc pareil ça marche moyen
d'ailleurs il est pro il est bien
possible que les bois que les dragons
chinois ont sur la tête viennent
directement des bois des cervidés
fossiles que les chinois trouvaient dans
les grottes que d'ailleurs la
pharmacopée chinoise est un très riche
de fossiles du coup les chinois ont
depuis longtemps exploiter les gisements
fossilifères donc là la limite chez
d'accord oui les dragons
occupe une importante place dans les
motifs les faïences les produits et les
broderies et c'est parce que il ya une
très forte influence culturelle des
longues goûts et des longues ni je crois
donc les dents de dragons et les autres
dragons dans la pharmacopée chinoise
donc à la limite là là il ya un très
directe a retracé entre fossiles et
mythes des dragons effectivement mais
pas spécialement les dinosaures par
contre dommage
raté on explique tout ça une fois de
plus dans notre vidéo stop science
dragon et dinosaures l'angleterre comme
d'autres pays à conserver la légende de
saint georges qui triompha sur le dragon
dont leur père était une grotte
oui comme quasiment tous les saints de
toutes les villes d'europe
tous les saints de toutes les villes
d'europe ont triomphé de la même manière
d'un dragon et ça ça veut peut-être dire
que de base c'était juste une histoire
c'était juste une mythologie qui s'est
ensuite régionaliser en fait c'était une
mythologie général qui s'est régionalisé
mais sinon non pas convaincu ajoutons le
témoignage de sertir irlandais du 10ème
siècle et sa rencontre avec ce qui
semble avoir été instiguées or non là
par contre je
en irlande est du 10ème siècle qui
rencontrait un style aux orres attend
donc un irlandais du 10ème siècle dit
avoir rencontré la sténose or l'histoire
vient de charles lesellier et brian
russell d'anciens secrets de la bible
donc l'histoire originale l'histoire
originale vient déjà d'un truc de
propagande créationnistes voilà donc
encore une fois le dinosaure qui se mord
la queue
donc voila et on y explique que le
l'irlandais a décrit une bête avec une
une queue en métal dans une queue avec
des pointes en métal et des et des
griffes et des potes et peste
et des griffes et des pâtes très épaisse
alors c'est dommage parce que les
griffes s'étaient cosworth est pas
vraiment des griffes qu'il avait c'était
plutôt des sabots donc en plus ça marche
pas allez bisous bécaud bisous bécaud
l'histoire de l'irlande est enfin le
livre historique européen du 16e siècle
historia et animale sommes donc il faut
bien rappeler que c'est un livre
historique répertorie un certain nombre
d'animaux qui serait aujourd'hui classé
parmi les dinosaures un naturaliste au
célèbre de cette époque ulysse al-droe
vendu ce fait étape par exemple d'un
affrontement entre un paysan du nom de
batista et un dragon dans la description
correspond à un tennis trophy us qui
n'est pas un dinosaure
dommage ce combat eu lieu le 13 mai 1572
près de bologne en italie et se solda
par la mort du dragon dont on n'a rien
gardé important c'était en 1572 on en a
des restes de 1572 mais curieusement n'a
rien de regarder de ce dragon donc
dommage on peut pas vérifier notre part
des pétroglyphes motifs gravés dans la
roche ont été découverts représentant
des animaux aux allures de dinosaures
par pitié ne me parlait pas encore de
celui de encore justement
bref au cours des siècles les dragons
ont été très présent dans la vie des
hommes
tellement présent qu'on n'a jamais pu en
faire une description correct non mais
c'est sa selle et ils ont été très
présent dans la vie des hommes mais
tellement présent quand on n'en a jamais
fait un dessin ou une représentation
correcte ou ayew une description ou quoi
que ce soit tellement tellement présent
or la description de ces animaux
concorde avec ce que nous savons des
dinosaures ben je sais pas donne la
description déjà parce que là tu viens
juste de nous balancer une série de tu
viens juste de nous balancer une série
d'anecdotes ou tu nous dis même pas à
quoi ressemble le dinosaure en question
entre guillemets dinosaures parce que tu
as nitro fut ce une fois de plus ça
marche pas mais voilà moi je n'aurai
aucun mal à imaginer qu'un italien
combattu un crocodile limite un
crocodile c'est plus c'est plus diffus
c'est moins difficile d'imaginer un
crocodile en italique un dinosaure
kalin aux arts vivants aussi la bible
mentionne-t-elle ces créatures même
celles qui vivaient dans la mer où
sillonnaient le ciel
oui donc en gros elle la bible mentionne
des animaux dans la mer dans le ciel
mais aucun qui correspond à dinosaures
sur terre sur la terre ferme
il existe d'ailleurs quantité de preuves
historiques autre que celle ci de la
coexistence de bêtes et des êtres
humains de ces bêtes et des êtres que
nous disent ces ossements abala si on
commence à parler doucement je vais
commencer à pouvoir m'amuser aussi moins
un peu parce que là ça commence à faire
long j'en suis qu'à la moitié ou là des
éléments de preuves physiques nous
permettent également de conclure que les
ossements de dinosaures ne sont pas
âgées de millions d'années en effet des
scientifiques de l'université d'état du
montana ont découvert des ossements de
t-rex qui n'était pas entièrement
fossilisé c'est vrai on a découvert
qu'il y avait du collagène à l'intérieur
d'ossements de t-rex et on a même pu
séquencer les protéines qui se
trouvaient à l'intérieur
est ce que ça veut dire que ces
ossements n'était pas fossilisées non il
était définitivement fossilisés et tout
en cailloux à dire tu n'aurais pas pu
soulever cette hausse de t-rex l'os de
la petite histoire de cette hausse de
t-rex du montana pour vous la raconter
en entier donc c'est alors je sais plus
si c'est bakker ou corners je crois que
c'est déjà corner cdja corner donc qui a
découvert ces sept ossements dans le
mode cette hausse de t-rex dans le
montana
c'est un énorme fémur si je me rappelle
bien et cet énorme fémur donc était
tellement fossilisé il était tellement
lourd tellement transformé en pierres
qu'ils ont dû le couper en deux pour
pouvoir le transporter et sont venus le
chercher en hélicoptère et c'est dans
l'hélicoptère après que l'os était
découpée en deux que orne eure justement
regardant la coupe fraîche de l'os s'est
rendu compte que il restait encore
quelque chose qui ressemblait vaguement
de la matière organique
donc cette hausse il est complètement
fossilisé il est complètement fossilisés
c'est jusque il reste encore un tout
petit peu de protéines
à l'intérieur un tout petit peu de
collagène parce que le collagène est une
molécule extrêmement résistante
et la seule chose que ça démontre c'est
pas que l'os de t-rex n'était pas
fossilisées ça démontre juste qu'on n'a
pas encore bien compris tous les tenants
et aboutissants du processus de
fossilisation et notamment celui du
collagène voilà et qu'on a peut-être un
peu trop vite assumer que toutes les
traces organiques avait disparu de
fossiles même quand il avait des
millions d'années donc très cher en
dessous irin genesis ta gueule
sincèrement d'ailleurs certaines
sections de ces ossements ressembler à
du tissu osseux frais et contenaient
même ce qui semblait être des globules
sanguins et de l'hémoglobine non c'est
pas certaines sections de ces ossements
c'est une fois qu'ils ont dissous toute
la partie fossilisé il ya effectivement
des petits tissus mous donc les fameuses
fibres de collagène qui sont ressortis
c'est très très loin d'être du tissu
osseux frais là comme tu parles c'est
n'importe quoi est ce que tu racontes
par contre les globules sanguins je suis
d'accord ils ont effectivement retrouvé
des globules des globules rouges
alors je sais pas s'ils sont fossilisés
ou s'ils sont semi fossilisés au wat
donc je vous ai retrouvé l'article qui
parle de ces globules rouges
donc les globules rouges dans un os de
dinosaure vieux de 75 millions d'années
paru en 2015 dans la revue nature
communications
j'en profite d'ailleurs pour dire que
c'est pas des créationnistes qui
trouvent ces choses là un bizarrement ce
sont toujours des scientifiques donc ce
que ça veut dire globalement c'est que
les scientifiques sa s'accommode très
bien toutes ces découvertes de la
théorie de l'évolution s'accommode très
bien de toutes ces découvertes et
globalement comme je le disais ça remet
plus en question notre connaissance du
phénomène de fossilisation que la
théorie de l'évolution en elle-même ou
même la datation des fossiles
donc voilà c'est pas les créationnistes
qui font des découvertes et dix rats
vous avez vu on vous a piégé non non
c'est les créationnistes qui reprennent
les découvertes des scientifiques qui
jusqu'à présent les gênait pas et 10ème
et vous avez vu ça normalement ça
devrait vous gênez fait banon se gêne
pas je veux dire ça veut juste dire
qu'il ya un truc qu'on avait mal compris
ah mais non mais ça veut dire que les
fossiles ils sont super récent banon
puisqu'ils sont fossilisés je veux dire
l'os il est transformé en cailloux
qu'est ce que tu veux de plus brefs
donc voilà j'en profitais juste pour
dire que voilà les créationnistes ils ne
font rien voilà ils ne font rien et ne
produisent rien ils ne font que détruire
ce sont des destructeurs de ce sont des
destructeurs ce ne sont pas des contes
des bâtisseurs voilà bref donc ils n'ont
aucun [ __ ] de mérite voilà c'est tout
ce que je veux dire ils ont pas de
mérite
donc voilà les fameuses structure en
forme de globules bon ça vaut ce que ça
vaut
ça a été observée par section fine sur
des morceaux très dense de d'un os et
donc ça ressemble plus ou moins à l'eau
forme concave qu'on les globules chez
les oiseaux en fait donc et c'est pour
ça que ça a été identifié comme des
globules rouges alors oui parle d'eux
comme je le dis parle de érythrocytes
like structure donc ça veut dire des
trucs qui ressemble à des globules
rouges donc ils vont pas aussi loin que
de dire ce sont des globules rouges
ce sont des trucs qui ressemble à des
globules rouges et ils sont pas alors je
sais pas si je crois pas que eux mêmes
savent s'ils sont fossilisés ou non ils
disent que c'est fibreux
voilà il ya quelque part willis voit la
fibre voilà pour eux ces fibres voilà et
si vous voulez voir en français il ya
l'équivalent ici en français des
globules rouges découvert dans d autres
dinosaures donc moi d'ailleurs vous
voyez là d'un seul coup on est passé de
ça des trucs qui ressemble à des
globules rouges à des globules rouges
donc moi je suspecte même les mecs qui
écrivent en soi une genesis de se baser
sur les vulgarisateurs scientifiques qui
en rajoute des tonnes par rapport à aux
vrais articles scientifiques mais bref
donc il n'était pas entièrement
fossilisés mon cul si ces ossements
datent vraiment de dizaines de millions
d'années alors les cellules sanguines
ainsi que l'hémoglobine serait
totalement désintégré en tout cas il
faisait suffisamment la gueule pour
qu'on puisse pas les identifier
clairement notre part il ne devrait pas
y avoir de tissus osseux ferait si ces
ossements ont réellement des millions
d'années il n'y en a pas ça tombe bien
les scientifiques raconte alors les
scientifiques raconte source 27 quai
quinet nos scientifiques assez marie
scheider dans son bus livre de risle
jurassic park
donc ça va ah oui mais attend voir le
rapport dans creation décrivant les
analyse méticuleuse démontre que
l'hémoglobine était bien présente donc
ce qu'il cite je redoute qu'en fait ce
qu'il va nous citer là dans sept sites
dans cette phrase
c'est en fait le rapport qui a été le
rapport à propos de cet article qui est
paru dans la revue créationnistes
création voilà donc encore une fois fait
pas dire à marie schveizer ce qu'elle
n'a pas dit voilà marie schweitzer est
une scientifique très sérieuse les gens
qui bossent sa création ne le sont pas
une lueur ambrée provenait d'une fine
lamelle dose de tiris placé sous
l'objectif d'un microscope des murmures
d'étonnement se répandirent dans le
laboratoire qu'elle avait focalisé
l'objectif sur un détail des vaisseaux
ce qui nous avons jusqu alors échappés
des petits objets auront du nom d'un
rouge translucide avec une coupe avec un
centre de couleur foncée des globules
sanguins
c'est bien ce qu'évoquait leur forme et
leur localisation pourtant les cellules
sanguines sont entièrement composé d'eau
et n'aurait pas pu être préservée dans
un tyrannosaure vieux de 65 millions
d'années or l'échantillon d'eau ce qui
nous avait haute
enthousiasmée provenait d'un beau
spécimen presque entier de tyrannosaure
rex déterré en 1990 lorsque l'équipe
avait introduit ce dinosaure au
laboratoire nous avions d'ailleurs
remarqué que certaines zones profondes
de l'os long de la jambe n'était pas
complètement fossilisés pourtant nous
estimons que ces éléments appuie la
thèse sur laquelle nos coupes dose de
t-rex aurait pu contenir des fragments
préserver dème et d'hémoglobine
il faudra toutefois approfondir ses
travaux avant de pouvoir annoncer sans
le moindre doute que des composés
sanguins sont en effet présents dans les
tissus 2 dans les tissus dans les tissus
de ce spécimen de tyrannosaure il manque
un mot oui bah merci d'avoir coupé tous
les passages où elle disait que ça ne
change rien au reste enfin on a retrouvé
des zones au fossilisé d'un dinosaure
sur le versant nord de l'alaska
les siens des scientifiques
créationnistes ont d'ailleurs recueilli
des spécimens de ces eaux congelés et
non fossilisés en alaska ce non non non
non les feux les adrover d'alaska les
hadrons jordan inscrits sont fossilisés
mec note 29 28 et 29 dec build and
others flotte de north slope ovale ascad
journal of vertebrate paleontology ça va
être très facile à trouver et on va
pouvoir voir directement après de
premières mains voilà que ce sont bel et
bien des fossiles et rien d'autre que
des fossiles et c'est quoi son autre
référence le temps que sa charge ses
petits d'avis de création music man
watts
qu'est ce que tu racontes mec bref voilà
un dinosaure à bec de canard récoltés en
adresse cas voilà donc c'est en alaska
on voit bien à [ __ ] bien évidemment il
n'y a pas d'image
ah si il ya des images à 10 dont il est
frais au qui l'effraie sept ans regarde
on n'arrive même pas reconnaître que
c'est le 1 c'est un tibia gauche et ça
c'est quand même de l'os congelés ça
c'est de la qualité de préservation ma
gueule ça ressemble vraiment à de l'osce
qui a passé lui qui restait dans la
glace a été préservé magnifiquement
alors et dans la description dans la
description d'où est ce qu ils disent
que ça vient
les adrs les méthodes à droz or été
collectées en 61 et ont été envoyés au
juge qui colle sur v il a envoyé les au
texas muséum a évidemment si les envoie
au texas a va être interprétée par des
les créationnistes donc ils ont été
retrouvés sur les bords de la colleville
river ainsi qui a été relocalisée en
1984 le site très accessible par bateau
ou par elie cohen qui parle d'un très
accessible et il ya eu beaucoup de
vandalisme maintien n'ont ils pas dit
par ailleurs que les créationnistes 1
est-ce que c'est pas ça qui dit des
scientifiques créationnistes d'ailleurs
recueilli des spécimens de ces eaux
congelés et là je lis et la jolie jolie
vandalisme
tiens donc tiens donc
donc le transport dans l'herbe n'était
impossible vandalisme une semaine donc
le annoncé pour prévenir le vandalisme
bah oui bah en même temps ils ont ils
ont caché la localité pour prévenir le
vandalisme pas de toute façon et de ce
que je disais c'est que du coup ce
finalement ils ont quand même réussi à
le trouver le site donc ça le site est
situé dans la peur colleville groupe qui
est dans le creux qui est crétacé et qui
est en discordance avec dû plier au
pléistocène
en gros donc il n'est pas dans la glace
voilà alors il ya effectivement des eaux
qui ont été trouvés sur le bord de la
rivière qui devait donc être dans la
rivière gelée mais par contre les
quand tu remontes le site jusqu'à
l'affleurement originelle ce que eux ont
fait et ce que n'ont pas fait ces
crétins de créationnistes et battu
retrouve le site et le site il est dans
le upper colleville groupe donc il est
dans le caillou voilà donc fin du couple
est merci bye bye
certes les les évolutionnistes ne
manquerait pas de dire que ces ossements
sont restés congelés pendant plusieurs
millions d'années depuis que ces
dinosaures sont supposés avoir disparu
pourtant il est impossible
non c'est pas du tout ça que j'ai dit tu
vois moi j'ai dit non non ça vient du
caillou ça a roulé de la falaise et
après ça a été congelé dans la rivière
voilà ce que dirait un évolutionniste
parce que je suis évolutionniste connard
pourtant il est impossible que d autres
puissent survivre à des millions
d'années d'existence sans être
déminéralisée c'est un effet un
casse-tête pour celui qui croit à une
ère des dinosaures remontant à des
millions d'années mais pas pour celui
qui fonde son raisonnement sur la bible
ouais pour celui qui fonde son résonne
pour celui qui pense que les
évolutionnistes sont des abrutis oui ça
peut être un casse tête
mais celui qui celui qui connaît un
évolutionniste et qui lui a posé la
question saura que sa réponse n'est pas
celle que tu crois qu'elle est voilà
comment j'ai les dinosaures et quel
était leur comportement on sait pas fin
de l'histoire
julien tu va nous inventer quoi tu va
nous inventer que tous les comportements
que non bon bref ne faisons pas de
procès avant d'avoir lu les films du
genre jurassic park où le monde perdu
dépeignent la plupart des dinosaures en
carnivores agressif
tuez moi c'est pourquoi je fais des
choses comme ça pourquoi je m'inflige
des lectures pareil va chier va chier va
chier va chier de dinosaures carnivores
agressif mais chez les scientifiques qui
leur ont dit de faire
pourtant la simple présence de dents
pointues ne révèle rien du comportement
d'un animal ni forcément de son régime
alimentaire
elle établit tout simplement le type de
dents qu'il possédait pour déchiqueter
sa nourriture
même si par contre l'étude des
excréments fossilisés coprolithe a en
effet permis de déterminer les habitudes
alimentaires de certains dinosaures à
l'origine avant l'avènement du pêcher
tous les animaux y compris les
dinosaures étaient végétariens
en effet la genèse 1.30 déclare à tout
animal de la terre à tout oiseaux du
ciel et à tous ceux qui se déplacent sur
la terre à ceux qui animent et à ceux
qui est animé de vie je donne tout r2
verte pour nourriture
oui bah ça veut dire que la nourriture
est à la base de la chaîne alimentaire
ça veut pas forcément dire qu'il ya pas
de carnivores 1 et cela se passe ainsi
bah oui mais ça c'est ouvert
interprétation le dire je donne tout
herbe verte pour nourriture alors ils
étaient herbivores mais strict parce que
dans ce cas là autant interprétée cette
phrase à fond il était à revivre strict
il mangeait pas de fruits il mangeait
pas de feuilles
il mangeait pas de tubercules il
mangeait que de l'herbe
même les êtres humains tout n'importe
quoi alors je vais te dire un truc
l'herbe l'herbe
il ya des petits cristaux de silice à
l'intérieur qui te bouffe complètement
les dents c'est pour ça que les arts
vivants ont les dents plate et qu'un
humain pourrait pas manger de l'herbe
parce que ça lui boufferait les dents
que tu soit croyant ou pas voilà
un nom mais interprète ton truc comme il
faut interprète ton truc à fond le dire
si tu as décidé de dire qu'ils étaient
végétariens non ils étaient herbivores
il mangeait que de l'herbe strictement
c'est ce que dit la bible ta gueule tu
contredit la bible d'agl merde donc
avant l'avènement du péché même t-rex
manger des plantes avec ses énormes
dents pointues
c'est pour ça qu'il a disparu d'ailleurs
c'est qu'il est un peu qu'on tire à aix
il ad énormes dents pointues et il est
incapable de mastiquer alors fatalement
ils mangeaient des plantes non mais il
croit je veux dire il croit koala il
croit que l'on la vente le concept les
dents pointues c'est avec les carnivores
il croit que c'est pas observable dans
le monde actuel je veux dire lee weight
le mec il a vu une fois son chat se
purger en mangeant de l'herbe il a dit
ah t'as vu tous les animaux sont
herbivores le dire de merde merde merde
quoi je veux dire là à quel niveau de
négationnisme de la biologie faut
arriver pour en a pour dire un animal
qui a que des dents pointues center du
bord ça marche ça marche
il est incapable de mastiquer les
incapable de couper l'herbe il est
incapable il n'a pas le corps pour la
digérer les herbes il a il n'a pas la
chambre de fermentation qu'il faut là on
le sait parce qu'on a les côtes
il n'a pas la chambre de fermentation
qu'il faut pour 10 g laird les traces
d'usure sur les dents ne sont pas celles
d'un herbivore on peut le voir ça aussi
parce que je le rappelle l'herbe laisse
des traces sur les dents parce qu'il ya
des cristaux de silice et la cellulose
aussi laisse des traces des petites
rayures sur les dents ça se voit aussi
ellos aussi l'os en l'occurrence l'ès
des petites ponctuation sur les dents et
quand on regarde les dents de t-rex on
voit des ponctuations et pas des rayures
donc ça veut dire qu'ils mangeaient de
l'os et on a des [ __ ] de crottes de
t-rex on a des coprolithe de t-rex des
déchirures des bouses énormes qui sont
truffés d'ossements ta gueule
ta gueule ta gueule ta gueule voilà on a
des coprolithe de t-rex gigantesque
bourg
de ce qu'est ce que tu veux de plus on a
des dinosaures qui sont retrouvés avec
des contenus stomacaux on le sait ce
qu'ils mangeaient on a le baryonyx il a
du poisson dans le bide
tu vas me dire que le poisson c'était de
l'herbe à l'époque continuons or
certains contestent cette conclusion
citant les grosses dents de cet immense
dinosaures qui servait insiste-t-il à
attaquer des animaux et les contenus
stomacaux et les ponctuations et les
analyses isotopiques je peux aussi tant
par les drames et aux morts
vivement que ce paragraphe s'arrête là
s'il me relance encore là dessus des
analyses isotopiques qui montre là que
la fragmentation des isotopes des de la
chimie de l'os est celle d'un carnivore
et pas d'un herbivore quoi va chier
vachier va chier va chier aie aie aie
aie
et j'oubliais mais t-rex puisqu'on parle
de t-rex t-rex on a juste ni plus ni
moins qu'une dent qui est resté planté
dans une [ __ ] de vertèbres d'adp rose
or et en ahl fossiles je rappelle donc
on a une dans la plante et à l'intérieur
de l'âme vertèbres de la dhr aux ors et
le tout c'est fossilisés ensemble et en
plus il ya un espèce de cale osseux qui
s'est formée autour de la de la dent du
t-rex et qui montre que le t-rex la mort
du quand il était vivant
la danse et péter dans la vertèbre et
qu'ensuite sahara cicatriser part au
dessus et tu va encore me faire croire
que le t-rex et végétarien mais va chier
vaches il est pourtant ce n'est pas
parce qu'un animal possède des grosses
dents pointues qui les carnivores en
effet la seule certitude que l'on puisse
avoir c'est qu'il a de grosses dents
pointues faire reculer avec des ailes
des conclusions comme ça te faire
[ __ ]
même si dans l'absolu je suis d'accord
qu effectivement avoir des grosses dents
pointues c'est pas forcément signe
d'être carnivores dans le cas je veux
dire dans le cas du t-rex tu as choisi
juste le mauvais exemple mec t'as juste
tellement mal choisis ton exemple dans
le cadre du t-rex ça a été vérifiée sur
vérifié et revérifié tu crois que tu es
le premier à avoir
tu crois que tu es le premier à te dire
peut-être que dents pointues ça veut pas
forcément dire carnivores mais va te
faire [ __ ]
va te faire ce domaine en effet de
nombreux animaux vivants aujourd'hui
sont doté de dents pointues alors qu'ils
sont essentiellement herbivores le panda
géant en est un exemple le panda géant
est un très mauvais exemple c'est un
animal anciennement carnivore qui est
devenus herbivores sur le tard ils ne
mangent que des bambous il est possible
que ses dents pointues furent
merveilleusement conçu pour son régime
de bambou non c'est dans
merveilleusement conçues ont été
merveilleusement conçu à la base pour
manger de la viande
il sait seconde herman adapté à la
nourriture en plus tu prends genre le
pire exemple possible parce que c'est
précisément
disons le panda il avait complètement
une dentition de carnivores comment ça
se fait qu'il ait larbi bord et
l'évolutionnisme dit bah c'est normal il
s'est adapté tardivement à l'herbe ivory
le évolutionniste et dit il est
merveilleusement conçu pour un régime de
bambou bah non c'est le principe même du
départ et justement il n'a pas une
dentition merveilleusement conçu pour le
bamboo des conquois donc affirme afin
d'expliquer pourquoi cet herbivore
possède des dents ressemblant à celle
des carnivores d'aujourd'hui
l'évolutionnisme se trouve contraint de
dire que le panda géant avait évolué
cieux évoluer en tant que carnivores
mais c'est ensuite converti en mangeurs
de bambou bah oui c'est exactement ce
qui s'est produit
tous les proches parents du panda géant
sont des carnivores souffre le panda
géant
c'est un ours
le design bourse enfin c'est un ours qui
fait partie de la grande famille des
carnivores à le dire donc oui bashy
bashy les chauves souris quand elles se
nourrissent selon leur espèce de fruits
du nectar d'insectes de petits animaux
ou encore de sang mais leur dentition ne
nous permet pas de déterminer la nature
de leur régime alimentaire
j'aurais était
mende pote à moi qui viendrais te casser
la gueule pour avoir dit ça mais
tellement tellement tout genre genre on
peut pas différencier les chauves-souris
nectar ivor des chauves-souris qu'à
aller bat dentition alors la dentition
des chauves-souris premières images je
crois qu'en plus ces genres premières
images de google scholar de base d'anti
shon voilà insectivores à des molaires
pour déchirer la nourriture
omnivore a aussi des molaires pour
déchirer mais vous voyez que la forme
déjà et pas la même les là quand il est
omnivore les dents sont un peu plus
large
alors que là elles sont plus étroites et
ensuite frugivores qui sert à broyer et
à écraser voilà beaucoup plus plate avec
vous voyez là cette espèce de truc en v
qui n'est pas aussi prononcée chez cette
chauve souris frugivores je peux même
aller vous chercher la nectarine bord
juste pour qu'on une chauve-souris
nectar ibor juste pour qu'on rigole pas
regarder les chauves-souris nectar ivor
regarder ça c'est une chauve-souris
nectar ivor mais non la dentition c'est
là même la tronche c'est la même tout
est pareil y'a aucun souci un bordel
bordel mais fermez là quoi voilà les
voilà les chauves-souris nectar yvorne
dirigeants non cela même dentition a
aucun moyen n'a aucun moyen de savoir
que celle là les nectars ivor à n'ont
aucun nom à part cet énorme museau parce
qu'elle a une énorme langue justement
parce que comme les comme les papillons
elles butinent le nectar mais n'ont
aucun aucune différence donc bon c'était
juste la première image google mec
c'était la première image google dans ta
langue en plus parce que ça a été
traduit de l'anglais
donc non bullshit archers pas qu'ils
aient référence 33 mes références 33
adam référence 33 forcément tu te
réfères au magazine création voilà
forcément tu devrais faire un magazine
créationnistes lacombe tu dit de la
merde
cqfd et qu'en est il des ours aux
allures de carnivores mais qui sont
pourtant herbivores même fille même
chose que le panda bon ils sont plutôt
omnivore d'ailleurs les oursins et puis
l'ours polaire est pas exactement
herbivores donc ta gueule
en effet certains jours sont herbivores
et beaucoup d'autre si ce n'est la
plupart ont une alimentation
essentiellement végétarienne donc en
plus tueur et utilise le même argument
comme si c'était un argument différent
ça si c'est pas de la malhonnêteté
intellectuelle c'est parfait je dire
avant l'avènement du péché dieu a
qualifié le monde de très bons c'est
pour ça qu'il a dit faut que ça s'arrête
or certains rejettent cette harmonie
parfaite car il ne correspond pas à la
chaîne alimentaire qu'ils observent dans
le monde d'aujourd'hui
alors non les valeurs morales de notre
société actuelle considère la carne
ivory comme étant mal donc
en projetant nos propres valeurs morales
dans la genèse récit qui a été écrit il
y a six murs il ya plusieurs milliers
d'années je sais pas exactement quand il
ya 4000 ans je crois un truc comme ça
bref en projetant nos valeurs morales
dans un récit comme la genèse qui a été
écrit il ya plusieurs milliers d'années
ont fini par interpréter le montrait
bompard forcément il pouvait pas y avoir
de carnivores parce que notre propre
société considère la carne ivory qu'en
mettant moralement pas génial ce qui est
raisonnable en soit je veux dire je
critique pas ça mais notre société voilà
considère les carnivores comme des
méchants les herbivores comme des
gentils vous allez voir le premier
dessin animé avec des animaux comme
héros venu les carnivores sont les
méchants les herbivores sont les gentils
aller voir zoom tiens voilà pour pour
une critique de cette de ce concept
d'ailleurs donc voilà et c'est parce
qu'on vit dans cette société là quatre
mille ans plus tard qu on réinterprète
la genèse en disant si dieu a dit que
c'était très bon c'est qu'ils étaient
forcément végétarien parce que les
carnivores c'est pas très bon voilà
donc encore une fois non juste non il
est cependant illusoire que de rejeter
le récit de la genèse du fait de l'état
du monde de l'état actuel du monde à
savoir maudit par le péché donc atteint
par la mort et les conflits qui en
résulte tout a changé à cause du péché
ben non puisque dieu a tué un truc pour
habiller adam tout n'a pas changé à
cause du péché dieu a tué un truc avant
le péché tu l'as dis toi même je ne cite
pas la bible je te cite toi je reprends
pas la bible en disant est ce qu'il dit
des bêtises non non c'est toi qui l'a
dit juste avant
c'est pourquoi paul dit que la création
avec que la création actuelle soupir il
faut au contraire appréhender le monde à
travers une perspective biblique afin de
pouvoir le comprendre
non d'aucuns prétendent que dans un
monde idéal les humains les animaux
auraient tout de même souffert en effet
ces personnes postulent que même temps
avant l'avènement du péché à dents ou un
animal aurait pu fouler des créatures
minuscules sous son pied ou ces rafles
et contre une branche
certes ces situations se produisent dans
le monde déchu d'aujourd'hui car il
était parfait et souffrent des
conséquences de la malédiction
toutefois il est impossible
d'interpréter la bible à travers un
prisme laïque et ainsi insisté que le
monde avant l'avènement du péché était
identique à celui que nous parce que
nous apercevons aujourd'hui car nous
ignorons ce à quoi ressemblait à un
monde parfait continuellement restaurer
et entièrement soutenue par la puissance
de dieu
en effet nous avons jamais vécu la
perfection tel que l'ont connu adam eve
avant le l'avènement du péché sinon tu
parles de dinosaures à un moment où
vient cependant les écritures nous donne
quelques petits aperçus en 2 09 40 ans
ni leurs vêtements ni leurs sandales ne
se sont usés lorsque dieu soutient
parfaitement toute chose luge et la
douleur sont simplement hors de question
n'empêche que ces sandales était fait en
cuillère un nom tu crois pas considérons
par exemple jadak nain lorsqu'il sortit
de la fournaise est dégagé par l'odeur
de feu le seigneur neymar n'a pas et le
boeuf des pas tout ça ça n'a rien à voir
avec les dinosaures est là la chaîne
alimentaire le comporte des sang et or
le monde d'aujourd'hui a été
radicalement transformé par le péché la
chaîne alimentaire le comportement des
animaux nos jours qui allait encore
changer suite au déluge ne
donc pas servir de modèle pour
interpréter la bible en effet seule la
bible nous explique pourquoi le monde et
devenir ainsi voile alors c'est vrai que
là pour le coup c'est gentil d'avoir mis
cette parenthèse parce que j'avais
négligé ce détail
j'avais négligé ce tout petit détail
mais si la carne ivory est apparu après
le péché originel
ça veut dire que durant le déluge et
donc à l'intérieur de l'arche de noé les
animaux il aurait fatalement dû se
bouffer entre eux aussi un mais bon
effectivement ça allait encore changer
suite au déluge de la jeunesse up
pirouette esquive tu peux pas test au
tout début dieu donne à adam et eve la
domination sur les animaux dieu les
bénit et leur dire produisez vous voilà
et ça c'était ça c'est typiquement une
philosophie il ya 4000 ans a dominé les
animaux aujourd'hui on est beaucoup
moins sûre il faut dominer les animaux
va donc c'est encore une fois tu
interprètes à travers ton prisme
d'occidental moderne quoi donc dominé
sur les poissons de la mer sur les
oiseaux le ciel et la terre
ça veut dire quoi dominer voilà si tu
peux pas les bouffées ça veut dire qu a
dominé savait rien dire pourtant lorsque
nous regardons le monde actuel nous fait
plutôt penser à hébreu de tu as mis sous
s'est tu as tout mis sous ses pieds en
effet en lui soumettant toute chose dieu
n'a rien laissé qui échappe à son
autorité maintenant pourtant nous ne
voyons pas encore que tout lui soient
soumis ainsi les rapports entre l'homme
et tous ceux qui l'entourent ont été
transformés par le péché bla bla bla bla
bla ils essayent de nous moraliser je
sais pas comment la plupart des gens y
compris la majorité des chrétiens ont
tendance à observer le monde dans son
état actuel c'est-à-dire caractérisée
par la mort la souffrance naga nous
devrions plutôt utilisé comme point de
départ la révélation divine à savoir la
bible afin de commencer à comprendre le
monde
alors pourquoi des crocs et des griffes
le docteur henri maurice celui qui se
prend pour dieu rappelez-vous figure
fondatrice du mouvement créationniste
moderne déclare alors pourquoi des crocs
et des griffes avant de pouvoir répondre
à la question de 6 des structures telles
que les crocs et les griffes faisait
partie de l'anatomie d'origine ou
représente plutôt d'être erreurs
récessif qui n'ont commencé à dominer
que plus tard grâce à un processus de
sélection ou encore sont le fruit de la
mutation suite à la malédiction ou
encore le résultat d'un autre
phénomène quelconque il faudra attendre
les résultats pour de plus amples
recherches
mesdames et messieurs henri maurice
fondateur ou fond de figures fondatrices
du mouvement créationniste nous dit que
par un processus de sélection
les animaux ont changé d'anatomie
[Rires]
mesdames et messieurs le créationnisme
par un processus de sélection naturelle
les espèces ont changé d'anatomie moi
j'ai rien d'autre à ajouter gérable non
mais c'est bien là tu te casses tout
seul les espèces ont évolué voilà les
espèces ont évolué voilà dès qu'ils ont
commencé à dominer que plus tard voilà
les grilles faisant partie de leur
anatomie sont apparus plus tard
donc elles ont évolué elles sont le
fruit de la mutation voilà j'ai même
plus besoin de travailler
j'ai même plus besoin de rien faire ils
font tout à ma place
regardez c'est dans le texte c'est dans
le texte figure fondatrice du mouvement
créationniste nous dit les espèces
évoluent fin du couple est générique au
revoir vous pouvez arrêter la vidéo
maintenant après c'est beau c'est beau à
ce niveau là j'ai même plus envie de
continuer là c'est beau c'est c'est la
conclusion parfaite après l'avènement du
péché dans le monde tout a basculé en
effet les espérances ont commencé à
évoluer qu'il est possible que les
animaux se soient mis à centre manger
dès ce stade là mais les armes et les
plantes les plantes le monde il n'était
pas parfait du coup pour les plantes
parce que les plantes elles sentent la
douleur 1
ça a été montrée ya pas longtemps quand
on quand une plante se fait mordre par
une chenille il ya un influx électriques
qui part dans la plante ça a été
démontrée ya pas longtemps
et j'en parlais déjà dans la vidéo que
j'avais fait à propos de la biologie des
plantes et qui s'intitulait stop science
la guerre silencieuse des végétaux si je
me rappelle bien voilà la guerre
silencieuse des végétaux donc j'en
parlais déjà
enfin des scientifiques en parlait déjà
il ya quatre ans à tel point que je
l'avais déjà dit il ya quatre ans dans
la vidéo il ya encore un article qui est
sorti récemment à ce propos les plants
étaient capables d'envoyer un signal
électrique et que une fois qu'elles ont
été mangés enfin une fois qu'elles ont
été mordues par un par une chenille et
on sait déjà depuis longtemps que les
acacias sentent quand ils se font mordre
par les par les antilopes et envoie des
signaux chimiques aux autres plantes
pour leur dire faites gaffe v'là les
antilopes
donc c'est quand même quelque chose
qu'on sait depuis un moment que les
plantes sont capables de sentir la
douleur en tout cas quelque chose qui
ressemble à de la douleur évidemment
c'est pas de la douleur c'est de
l'anthropocentrisme c'est de
l'anthropomorphisme même à ce niveau là
de dire que les plantes sont la douleur
mais il ya quand même quelque chose qui
ressemble à ce qu'on appelle la douleur
chez les plantes et en l'occurrence bah
du coup ça veut dire que le monde il
était pas parfait puisque on bouffe des
plantes dans le monde parfait alors bas
alors mais qu'est ce que tu réponds haas
a battu répond rien parce que tu me
parle pas mais bref voilà en effet il
est possible que les animaux sont miss
l'autre manger à ce stade là et comme on
se et comme il ya que les animaux qui
nous intéresse et que les plantes on
s'en fout bah voilà tout va bien en tout
cas arrivé au temps de noël c'est en ces
termes que dieu a décrit la situation
dure regarde à la terre et voici elle
était corrompu car toute chair avec en
plus sa voix sur la terre et ça ne veut
rien dire d'autre part dieu à changer le
comportement des animaux après le déluge
en effet le déclara vous serez craint et
redouté de tous les amis de tout animal
de la terre de toutes oiseaux du ciel et
de tous ceux qui se déplacent sur le sol
et de tous les poissons de la mer et
sont placés sous votre autorité
je vois pas la différence avec la phrase
d'avant
c'est vous dominerait tout et maintenant
ils sont sous votre autorité en cause
qu'est ce que ça change
adam et eve devait tout dominer nos et
maintenant on doit tout mettre sous son
autorité c'est quoi la différence
fondamentale
je ne vois pas mais la veut dire qu'ils
étaient à bord et l'autre veut dire
qu'ils étaient carnivores voilà 7 vous
ta gueule c'est magique
il sera dorénavant plus difficile pour
les humains de remplir leur mission de
domination qui leur est avait été
conféré dans la genèse 1.28 pourquoi
trouvons nous des fossiles de dinosaures
basset car à cause du déluge a
évidemment la formation de fossiles
nécessite un ensevelissement soudain pas
forcément non ça peut être progressif
aussi la peau de sushi or lorsqu'un
animal meurt il est généralement dévorer
ou se décompose jusqu'à ce qu'il n'en
reste plus aucune trace c'est pour ça
qu'il ya pas beaucoup de faux cils et
oui par contre la formation d'un fossile
exige des conditions bien particulières
premier temps ne permet de le préserver
et de le remplacer par des minéraux et
cetera autrefois les évolutionnistes
prétendez que le registre fossile s'est
déformée progressivement au fur et à
mesure que des animaux mouret se faisait
recouvrir graduellement par des
sédiments
bah c'est sûr que un registre fossile de
500 millions d'années ça a besoin de 500
millions d'années pour se former
qu'est-ce que tu essayes de nous dire là
ils ont néanmoins reconnu plus récemment
que ce registre fossile a dû subir des
processus catastrophique
oui une fois de temps en temps une bonne
grosse inondation ça aide à ensevelir
les animaux la formation de milliards de
faux cils à l'échelle de la planète est
au sein des couches parfois épaisse de
plusieurs kilomètres exige
l'ensevelissement rapide de la majorité
de ces organismes
pas forcément de la majorité je veux
dire quelques-uns une fois de temps en
temps suffisent mais x des longueurs à
urt e-sante de millions d'années
fatalement ça finit par créer une
certaine masse évidemment si tu admets
de base que la terre est jeune et
assimilant ya pas assez de temps pour
ensevelir tout ce monde là mais encore
une fois tu vas te basé sur un argument
circulaire je te vois venir mon petit je
te vois venir de nombreuses
évolutionniste au conseil d'aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs que le registre fossile s'est
formé rapidement non d'ailleurs tu ne
cite aucune source pour ça donc non mais
prétendent par contre que cela s'est
produit par petit hack ou espacer de
millions d'années
d'où tu sors cette idée là qui cale
évolutionniste au tennis à j'aurais aimé
savoir là pour le coup j'aurais aimé
avoir une source effectivement or selon
la bible au fil du temps la terre c'est
rempli de méchanceté les villains dieu a
créé a alors décidé d'envoyer un déluge
mondiale pour détruire toute créature
qui a souffle de vie sous le ciel et si
c'était le déluge qui avait enseveli
tous ces animaux ils seraient tous dans
la même couche
or ils n'y sont pas il ya plein de
couches différentes avec plein d'animaux
différents dans chaque couche en plus
c'est chiant 1
le déluge était-il sélectif je veux tu
es en train de me dire que le déluge et
sélectif ou alors tu es en train de
remettre en question toute la géologie
mondiale mais dans ce cas là ça veut
dire que même les gens qui cherchent du
pétrole savent pas ce qu'ils font
va chier puis dieu ordonne à noé de
construire un immense navire pour
transformer sa famille ainsi que des
spécimens de tous les animaux terrestres
à respiration aériennes que dieu
lui-même choisirait et enverrait à noé
mais il a choisi les dinosaures pour les
re tués après voilà c'est ça l'histoire
apprend là ces échantillons comprenez
certainement deux de chaque type de
dinosaure
comment on tire des dinosaures aussi pu
rentrer il aurait t'il pu rentrer dans
l'arche dans l'imaginaire général les
dinosaures sont d'immenses créatures qui
n'auraient jamais pu entrer dans large
et c'est vrai pourtant la taille moyenne
d'un dinosaure calculé par à partir de
squelettes découverts dans le monde
entier se situe entre celle d'un mouton
et d'un bison en effet de nombreux
dinosaures étaient de taille
relativement réduite le structure me mus
par exemple était la taille d'une
autruche et le conditionne natus n'était
pas plus grand qu'un coq
ouais mais alors là tu t'en sors avec la
taille moyenne machin chouette mais
qu'il sa répond toujours pas la question
de comment tu fais rentrer en argentine
aux orres dans ton [ __ ] darche
comment tu fais tenir brachiosaures
argentinosaurus je veux dire et
diplodocus je dis rien que ces trois là
temps mais un couple chaque et il reste
la place pour qui après seuls quelques
dinosaures atteignait des dimensions
hors normes
par exemple le brachiosaure et la pâtée
aux ors et encore il ne rivalisait pas
avec l'animal le plus grand du monde
d'aujourd'hui à savoir la baleine bleue
oui mais la baleine bleue at elle eu
besoin seulement d'aller dans l'arche
or les reptiles ont la capacité de
grandir tout au long de leur vie les
grands dinosaures étaient donc
probablement des individus très vieux
les dinosaures pont d or le plus grand
hub fossilisés de dinosaures jamais
retrouvé est d'environ la taille d'un
ballon de rugby
d'ailleurs même le plus grand dinosaure
étaient tout petits au moment de
l'éclosion n'oublions pas que les
animaux qui débarquait de l'arche devers
peupler la terre il aurait donc été
indispensable de sélectionner pour large
des jeunes adultes qui se trouverait
bientôt au sommet de leur vie
reproductive d'ailleurs de récents
travaux semblent sus indiqué que les
dinosaures on va subit des poussées de
croissance rapide à l'adolescence donc
voilà c'est parce qu'on a fait rentrer
des bébés dinosaures
bon par contre vu le taux de survie on
espère qu'ils vont ils vont tenir parce
que c'est pas évident il est donc fort
probable que dieu n'aurait envoyé que de
jeunes adultes à l'arche et non pas de
créateurs et non pas des créatures
complètement
d'aucuns pourraient soutenir que la
capacité de l'arche était suffisante
pour accueillir les quelques 600 espèces
de dinosaures répertoriés maintenant on
est plus à presque un millier mais on
est à plus d'un millier d'espèces pas
six ans pourtant genèse 6.201 firme
affirme que la cré les créatures
terrestres qui sont montés à bord de
l'arche étaient des spécimens
représentatif des types ou de catégories
d'animaux
la question qui se pose donc à quoi
correspond le mot type ou catégorie il
est ainsi constaté que les
créationnistes public de nombreuses
espèces peuvent se développer à partir
d'un seul type
pardon pardon il à halle il a été
constaté par des créationnistes biblique
que de nombreuses espèces peuvent se
développer à partir d'un seul type tu
veux dire d'un neuf peut sortir deux
espèces différentes du coin il existe
par exemple une foule de type de chats
dans le monde pourtant l'ensemble des
espèce féline sont probablement descendu
une poignée de type originel de chat bah
oui mais là tu confonds tu confonds
variabilité intraspécifique et
interspécifique tu es en train de le
redire encore que les espèces évoluent
tu es en train de nous dire quoi là en
effet les variétés actuelles se sont
développées par l'action de la sélection
naturelle maintenant nos banlieues
les plus créationnistes maintenant sur
la variation originale du contenu des
informations des gènes des premiers chat
produisant ainsi diverses combinaisons
combinaisons et sous ensembles de
données et donc les différents types de
chat il est tellement en train de se
mordre la queue qu'il est en train de
nous faire une leçon d'évolution de
biologie évolutive j'y crois pas il est
tellement perdu dans son trip qu'il nous
fait de la biologie évolutive
d'autre part les mutations erreur de
copiage de gênes au moment de la
production peuvent également contribué à
la variation tout en sachant que les
mutations correspondent à une
détérioration entraînant ainsi une perte
d'informations
je suis je suis évolutionniste mais non
je suis créationnistes je suis venu
sioniste mais je suis qu'un sioniste je
suis évolutionnistes et créationnistes
végétaux d'évolution pour exprimer mon
délire mais chez créationnistes mais je
vous jure que je suis il est en train de
devenir fou
il est en train de se mordre la queue
complètement
il est en train de craquer du slip il
nous balance que les mutations l on crée
des nouveaux chat mais qu'en même temps
ça crée pas de nouvelles informations
j'ai raison vous savez que j'ai raison
que vous avez tort
aller voir des films allez-vous faire
des films il est en train de devenir fou
on est aux trois quarts du tri qu'il est
en train de devenir complètement barge
il est même possible que la spéciation
maintenant oui j'ai eu raison de ne pas
m'arrêter en fait c'est beau c'est bout
ce qui est en train de se produire
mesdames et messieurs c'est beau mais
bien chers abonnés pardonnez moi mais je
suis en train d'apprécier ce que je suis
en train de faire la chanson qui fait
c'est un déblocage et pénitence et je
suis en train de qui fait il est même
possible que la spéciation swan et de
ses processus
ban il est en train de comprendre la
biologie évolutive le garant fur et à
mesure qu'il écrit
à noter toutefois qu'à spéciation
n'équivaut pas évolution non je
rappelais vous je suis créationnistes
[Rires]
chez évolutionniste moi je suis comme je
suis dit c'est bon j'ai besoin
d'évolution toi expliqué marc délire
mais je suis créationnisme et vous jure
qu'il faut que j'explique la révolution
puisqu'elle ce point à noter toutefois
que spéciation n'équivaut pas à
évolution entre guillemets dans le sens
darwinien puisqu'elle se produit à
partir d'informations préalablement créé
déjà présentes
non c'est juste des espèces qui change
ça n'a rien à voir avec de l'évolution
il s'agit donc d'un processus de
dégradation plutôt que d'une
augmentation de la complexité
bah oui mais l'évolution s'est pas
l'augmentation de la complexité à les
voir notre épisode stop science la
complexité l'évolution c'est pas de la
complexité
ainsi seulement quelques couples de
félins aurait été nécessaire à bord de
l'arche de noé
et attends je parlais de dinosaures a
merdé il convient également de souligner
que les noms de dinosaures ont tendance
à proliférer en effet on donne à nouveau
nom à quelques fragments d'os puis
maintenant non même s'il ressemble à
d'autres de tailles différentes
découvertes dans d'autres pays il est
probable que moins d'une cinquantaine de
catégories ou de types distincts de
dinosaures aurait suffi au bord de
l'arche de noé
[Rires]
j'invente au fur à mesure talent un
tanin
rappelons également que l'arche de noé
était absolument immense est donc
parfaitement capable de transporter le
nombre nécessaire d'animaux y compris de
dinosaures de toute façon j'ai raison ta
gueule deal cette phrase façon large de
noël et on la fera aussi grande qu'il
faudra pour faire rentrer tout nos
conneries voilà les animaux terrestres
qui ne se trouvait pas à bord de l'arche
y compris les dinosaures se noyèrent
nombreux furent en préserver dans les
couches de sédiments formé par le déluge
d'où les millions de faux cils il est
probable qu'une bonne partie des
fossiles de dinosaures fait également
ensevelies à cet époque à savoir il ya
quelques 4500 ans comme l'indiquent les
datations radio chronologique d'autre
part dans l'après déluge les événements
catastrophiques y compris l'ère
glaciaire n'aurait pas manqué et aurait
également formé des fossiles poste
diluvien enfin les formes contorsionner
de ces animaux préserver dans la hanche
leur immense nombre dans ces cimetières
de fossiles ne rapportant n'ya pas
d'immense nombre dans des cimetières de
fossiles il ya quelques endroits où on a
deux localement une très grande richesse
en fossiles mais ya pas d immenses
nombre l'endroit l'endroit d'ailleurs où
on a le plus fin les fossiles les plus
nombreux qu'on l'a sont d'ailleurs des
espèces marines comme les ammonites par
exemple à on en trouve des tetra chier
comment tu expliques ça avec ton déluge
un vu qu'elle savait nager
vous avez deux heures leur importante
distribution et la présence de
squelettes entiers sont autant de
preuves convaincantes que leur
ensevelissement rapinier témoigne d'un
déluge gigantesque tu viens laurence les
squelettes entiers maintenant tu viens
tu viens de te plaindre qui avait plein
de petits fragments et maintenant tu
nous parles de squelettes entiers
tu peux pas être cohérent 2000
buts tu peux pas être cohérente deux
paragraphes d'affilée non c'est trop
demander waouh mauvaise foi talila
valide alors
[Applaudissements]
bon allez ça fait deux heures et demi
que ça dure cet enregistrement donc
comme le dit jean claude dusse il est
temps de conclure de toute façon on a
atteint le point où le mec c'est
tellement embourbé dans ses arguments
qu'il s'est mis à nous faire de la
biologie évolutive donc voilà maintenant
vous savez pour contrecarrer les
arguments créationnistes il suffit de
les laisser parler et de les laisser se
manger lamentablement dans leurs propres
arguments et contre-arguments voilà s'il
suffit de les laisser parler et puis au
bout d'un moment ils finissent pas
s'embourber par vous dire que les
espèces ont évolué au final et par vous
parler mais oui mais il ya une genre de
sélection naturelle et merde je suis en
train de faire du darwinisme et non mais
je suis pas darwinien et bref voilà donc
maintenant j'ai envie de dire que son
tombeau est clos voilà y'a plus rien à
rajouter
donc voilà on va on va torche et la fin
voilà donc pourquoi ne voyons-nous pas
de dinosaures aujourd'hui parce qu'ils
sont morts j'ai envie de dire dès la fin
du déluge de noé sa famille et les
animaux sortir de l'arche
ainsi les dinosaures commencer une
nouvelle vie dans un nouveau monde tout
comme les autres animaux les dinosaures
sortir pour se multiplier repeupler la
terre il aurait certainement donc
quitter le lieu d'atterrissage de
l'arche de noé d'atterrissage
intéressant mots pour une marche pour un
bateau atterrissage de l'arche de noé
pour se disperser sur la surface de la
terre
ce sont d'ailleurs les descendants des
dinosaures là qui engendrèrent les
légendes de dragon mais oui parce qu'ils
crachent du feu et qui vole on vous l'a
dit cependant le monde qui le monde
qu'il dure repeupler à mais ça y est là
je viens de comprendre pourquoi les
dinosaures doivent survivre à l'arche de
noé c'est pour qu'ils puissent engendrer
les légendes des dragons ah oui parce
que je comprenais pas pourquoi en fait
le mec tenait absolument à ce que les
dinosaures survivent au déluge
alors que ces genres excuse absolue pour
justifier que les dinosaures ont disparu
bah oui c'est parce que dans sa logique
à lui en fait les dinosaures ont aussi
engendré les légendes des dragons et
fatalement ils ont dû vivre encore après
l'arche de noé pour ça
d'accord maintenant je veux maintenant
je comprends cependant le monde qu'il
dure repeupler était sensiblement
différent de celui qu'ils avaient connue
auparavant en effet le déluge il avait
dévasté
il serait désormais plus difficile de
survivre dans un tel environnement or à
l'issue du déluge dieu annonça à noé par
contre les grenouilles à elle aucun
problème mais les dinosaures ils ont
crevé les grenouilles elles ont eu aucun
crevé dieu annonça à noter que
dorénavant les animaux craindre et
l'homme et que leur chère pourrait
servir de nourriture en effet le monde
était devenu plus hostile même pour
l'homme afin de survivre les humains de
seront contraints d'apporter un
supplément d'origine animale aux
nutriments qui autrefois se trouvait en
abondance dans les plantes et c'est pour
ça qu'on a autant de récits d'hommes
chassant le
le dragon pour la nourriture et oui on
en a aucun ah pardon désolé
autant pour moi par conséquent la
capacité de survie à la fois des animaux
et des humains sera rudement mis à
l'épreuve
or force est de constater au vu du
registre fossile de l'histoire écrite de
l'humanité et du vécu des siècles le
récent que de nombreuses formes de vie
de notre planète n'y ont pas survécu
je suis d'accord c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que la biodiversité devrait
baisser hashtag mon art marque du début
de la vidéo
notre part il convient de rappeler qu'un
grand nombre de plantes et d'animaux
terrestres à la respiration aériennes
ont disparu depuis le déluge soit par
l'action de l'homme ou à la concurrence
avec d'autres espèces soit du fait de
l'environnement pose il vient désormais
plus hostile or une foule de catégories
sont encore une fois d' sont encore en
voie de disparition les dinosaures quant
à eux semblent avoir fait partie des
catégories est apte
pourquoi donc cet angle est là
là tu fais des hypothèses sur la bible
parce que nulle part dans la bible
seddiki à une race de reptiles géants
qui s'est éteint enfin une race de
reptiles de léviathan ou de whatever qui
s'est éteint donc là tu fais
complètement des hypothèses donc en fait
tu rajoutes des hypothèses là où les
scientifiques avaient des réponses un
maire pas ressasser les scientifiques
qui font du mystère un hashtag
hypocrisie pourquoi donc cet engouement
pour les dinosaures comparé au peu
d'intérêt que suscite par exemple la
disparition des fougères claudio clad au
fébus bas parce que t'es pas
paléobotaniste mais tu serais
paléobotaniste tu le saurais il
semblerait que les gens soient fascinés
voir passionné par le côté monstre
dinosaures en effet les évolutionnistes
ont su exploiter cette fascination et
par conséquent le monde voit les
évolutionnistes et le cinéma beaucoup
plus le cinéma que les évolutionnistes
d'ailleurs les évolutionnistes
finalement ils ont pas si bien fait leur
pub que ça comparé à hollywood le monde
s'est trouvée inondé d'une propagande
darwinienne focaliser sur les dinosaures
n'ont ni dans quel objet culturel
populaire basé sur les dinosaures
entendu parler de darwin correctement je
parle pas de tous les films où on te
balance une théorie d'armure pseudo
darwinienne bullshit non dans quel objet
de culture populaire on parle de darwin
correctement
jamais jamais même dans x-men la même
dans les films x men où tout est basé
sur l'évolution même là ils racontent de
la merde
donc non c'est ainsi que la philosophie
évolutionniste a imprégné la pensée
moderne
même chez les chrétiens 1 les pauvres
chrétiens c'est pourquoi lorsqu'on
demande par exemple à un zoo au pourquoi
il a développé un programme en faveur
des espèces menacées la réponse est
généralement du style nous avons déjà
perdu beaucoup d'espèces sur la terre
les animaux disparaissent tout le temps
il suffit de voir toutes les espèces qui
ont disparu pour toujours
il faut agir pour sauver ce qui reste
c'est en demande pourquoi les animaux
disparaissent il est très probable que
les explications seront du genre mais
c'est évident les humains les tuent ou
bien c'est la pénurie de nourriture la
destruction de l'environnement par
l'homme la maladie les problèmes
génétiques les catastrophes telles que
les inondations bref toutes sortes de
raisons quel rapport
quel est le rapport si en revanche vous
posez la question est bien qu est ce qui
est arrivé aux dinosaures la réponse
sera certainement nous l'ignorons non
les gens répondront météorite
les scientifiques ont proposé des
douzaines de scénarios possibles mais en
fait ça demeure un mystère
non ben non ils réinventent un mystère
encore une fois c'est toi là qui fait du
mystère là ils réinventent un mystère
encore une fois non les gens te
répondront météorites ou volcan ou les
deux mais voilà peut-être une des
raisons pour lesquelles les dinos et ils
ont raison
d'ailleurs peut-être une des raisons
pour lesquelles les dinosaures ont péri
et que nous n'avons pas mis en place à
ces tonneaux programme de protection des
espèces menacées
les facteurs provoquant la disparition
des dinosaures aujourd'hui tous liés au
péché de l'homme à savoir la malédiction
les conséquences du déluge un jugement
etc sont les mêmes phénomènes qui ont
entraîné l'extinction des dinosaures
donc c'est nous qu'on fait les conneries
c'est les dinosaures qui paye
ça c'est le carmin mec ça c'est la
justice de dieu donc et non mais
sérieusement sérieusement ce paragraphe
là ce paragraphe là il est en train de
nous dire qu'effectivement la justice de
dieu c'est nous qu'on fait les conneries
c'est les dinosaures qui disparaît ça
j'ai pas j'ai pas envie de dire que
c'est pas très catholique 1 mais c'est
quand même pas très catholique un mec
t'es tu vient d'insulter dieu je veux
dire tu viens ce paragraphe insultes
dieu si tu as un quelconque respect pour
dieu mec tu écris pas des conneries
pareilles
sérieusement
aux vaches y est les dinosaures ont ils
vraiment disparu il est impossible de
prouver qu'un organisme a disparu sans
connaître simultanément chaque recoin de
la surface de la terre
non tu vas pas aller par là par pitié on
a exploré que 5% des océans il ya
forcément à megalodon à ta gueule ta
gueule on a exploré les cinq sens les 5%
des océans dans lesquels on est censé
trouver megalodon ont été explorées et
là c'est pareil pour les dinosaures les
endroits où on est censé les trouver ont
déjà été explorée fais pas chier fais
pas chier
or des spécialistes ont déjà eu à rougir
lorsqu'après avoir déclarés disparus
certains animaux ces créatures ont été
retrouvées bel et bien vivante
gna gna gna gna coelacanthe gnagnagna
c'était au début du [ __ ] de xxème
siècle au début du [ __ ] de xxème
siècle le coelacanthe alors commence pas
à nous ressortir le coelacanthe
évidemment qu'on savait potes évidemment
qu'on ne savait pas autant il ya cent
ans qu'on en sait maintenant par exemple
des ex des explorateurs ont rencontré
des éléphants au népal dans les années
90 qui possédait de nombreuses
caractéristiques des mammouths
préférence 43 et bien d'où cette
histoire 43 encore le magazine création
au toujours pas une vraie référence
scientifique 1 citant aussi ces
scientifiques en australie qui ont
trouvé des arts vivants qu'il pensait
disparu avec les dinosaures
c'est comme si on avait découvert à
dinosaures vivants a déclaré l'un d'eux
à la je crois par contre qu'il va y
avoir une vraie référence
ah bah non c'est encore dans création
mais cette histoire là je la connais
d'ailleurs
oui c'est oui bah ce sont des arbres
comme les acacias comme les
et avocats ria comme les ginko ce sont
des arbres qui ont une origine très
ancienne mais ce ne sont pas des
dinosaures se sont pas des arbres
dinosaures d'ailleurs lorsque les
scientifiques découvrent des animaux et
des plantes qu'ils pensent avoir disparu
depuis longtemps il les appelle fossiles
vivants
or il existe des centaines de fossiles
vivants ce qui est fort gênant pour ceux
qui croient que la terre est âgée de
millions d'années non il existe des
centaines de fossiles vivants que parce
qu'il existe des centaines de définition
du mot fossiles vivants et qu'au bout
d'un moment tout est toute espèce peut
être qualifié de fossiles vivants à
partir du moment ta définition de
fossiles vivants c'est une espèce dont
on retrouve des fossiles même nous on
est des fossiles vivants on a des
fossiles d'homo sapiens donc je peux
même te dire qu'il ya des millions
d'espèces de fossiles vivants dans ce
cas parce que toutes les espèces sont
des fossiles vivants on a des fossiles
il existe potentiellement des fossiles
d' absolument toutes les espèces voilà
donc au bout d'un moment la raison pour
laquelle il existe autant de fossiles
vivants c'est parce qu'il existe à peu
près autant de versions de la définition
de ce qu'est un fossile vivant que
d'espèces dans le monde
voilà donc va chier et puis on a fait
une vidéo
et puis j'ai fait aussi une vidéo sur
voilà comment reconnaître les fossiles
vivants
donc les fossiles vivants vivant pour
les nuls j'ai oublié de maîtresses
vivant mais voilà allez voir cette vidéo
là vous en apprendrez plus sur les
fossiles vivants explorateurs et
autochtones en afrique affirme avoir vu
des créatures aux allures de dinosaures
oui j'ai aussi fait une vidéo sur le
mokélé mbembé vous pouvez aller la voir
aller voir la vidéo sur le mokélé mbembé
c'est aussi une histoire de merde ça ne
tient pas debout donc ciao
si ces observations se limitent
généralement à des zones excentrées tels
que des lacs au fond de la jungle
congolaise
les descriptions données correspondent
bien à celles de dinosaures oui la
raison pour laquelle elles viennent du
fond de la jungle c'est parce que les
descriptions qui viennent pas du fond de
la jungle tout de suite
elles sont moins crédible en amérique
une grotte ornée par des autochtones
semble représenter des dinosaures or si
les scientifiques veulent bien
d'accepter les seins de mahmoud se
trouvant également dans cette grotte
pourquoi roger tissot de dino
or sur ce 47,1 va peut-être parce que
c'est encore un magazine créationnistes
n'a en effet l'endoctrinement
évolutionniste selon lequel l'homme
n'aurait pas cohabiter avec les
dinosaures empêche la plupart des
scientifiques ne serait-ce que de
considérer la possibilité que ces
dessins pourrait représenter des
dinosaures oui mais non alors en
amérique en amérique il ya effectivement
un dessin d'un ptérodactyle mais qui
n'est en fait pas un ptérodactyle voilà
et c'est un français qu'il a des bonnes
caisse a donc le cake
donc voilà ça c'était le dessin que les
gens voyaient donc un dessin qui avait
était repassé au blanc sur la paroi de
la grotte qui avait été effectivement
pattes par lescar d'amérique
effectivement ça ressemble beaucoup à un
ptérodactyle c'est cette silhouette que
vous voyez là sauf qu'en fait quand on
regarde mieux la peinture bas c'est ça
qu'on voit donc voilà ça c'est la tête
du ptérodactyle ça c'est son aile et ça
c'est son autre elle essaie juste parce
qu'en fait la peinture avait été
repassés aux blancs que les gens ont cru
voir un ptérodactyle voilà il ya de la
grosse craie blanche des glaces qui
était passé par au-dessus probablement
par un créationniste d'ailleurs donc
voilà c'est la seule raison pour
laquelle il ya eu ça et puis bah ça bah
c'est un alligator
voilà les grosses des cayes sur le dos
et un alligator voilà bisous bécaud en
revanche aucun créationnistes n'aurait à
rougir si quelqu'un découvre est un
dinosaure vivent dans une jungle
ce serait par contre plutôt gênant pour
les évolutionnistes par contre c'est par
contre les créationnistes rougissent à
chaque fois que quelqu'un prétend qu'il
va trouver un dinosaure dans la jungle
et revient bredouille
1 à propos il est impossible de cloner
un dinosaure comme dans le film jurassic
park même si on dispose de son adn pour
la simple raison qu'il faudrait à
dinosaures femelle en effet les
scientifiques ont constaté que pour
cloner à l'animal
il faut l'oeuvre d'une femelle vivante
puisque le mécanisme que renferme
cytoplasme de l'oeuf est indispensable
au développement de la nouvelle créature
hors sujet pas si fou que ça mais hors
sujet des dinosaures et oiseaux
pourtant de nombreux évolutionniste ne
crois pas vraiment que les dinosaures
est effectivement disparu prenons le cas
de cette affiche placée en 1997 à
l'entrée de la volière
du zoo de cincinnati dans l'ohio et qui
pose la question les dinosaures ont-ils
vraiment disparu il ya des millions
d'années
et bien non sachez que les oiseaux sont
essentiellement des dinosaures moderne à
plumes et à queue courte
c'est le docteur john ostrom de
l'université de yale qui au milieu des
années 60 s'est mise à populariser
l'idée selon laquelle les dinosaures
rêve évolué pour devenir des oiseaux
cependant pas tous les évolutionnistes
sont d'accord c'est tout simplement
l'une de leur fantaisie rétorque à l'amf
et du cha en it aux log à l'université
ouais donc alan fait toute chose c'est
quand même pas paléontologues c'est un
ornithologue donc donc il n'est pas
exactement spécialiste de la question à
l'université north carolina et chapelles
il est l'un des principaux détracteurs
de la théorie dite des dinos aux oiseaux
ils ont tellement envie de voir des
dinosaures vivants qu'ils se croient
désormais capable de les étudier
indirectement à la mangeoire des oiseaux
du jardin
bah je vous rappelle le microraptor que
je vous ai montré tout à l'heure et puis
qui avaient des plumes
le dire qu'est ce qu'il vous faut de
plus un dinosaure avec des plumes voilà
bref en effet en recense de nombreuses
tentatives d'endoctrinement des
populations à l'idée que les oiseaux
seraient en fait des dinosaures à
jurassic world par exemple ah bah non
ça marche pas par exemple le 26 avril
1993 le magazine time publiée à la une
l'image d'un dinosaure oiseaux
aujourd'hui dénommée monique us munis de
plume une soi-disante forme
transitionnelle entre dinosaures et
oiseaux
élaboré à partir d'une découverte de
fossiles pourtant sans plumes harmonique
us et reconstruit avec des plumes parce
que évidemment c'est un théropodes
extrêmement dérive est donc très proche
des oiseaux c'est un alvarez ohrid si je
me rappelle bien mais effectivement il
n'y a pas l'air d'avoir le fossile en
lui-même a l'air d'être un squelette en
3d et pas une impression avec des clubs
donc il marque un point
effectivement il marque un point son été
plus judicieux de mettre microraptor qui
lui est préservée avec des plumes pour
le coup ou bien encore l'un des premiers
dinosaures à plumes a abordé était
découvert
donc si on tape dinosaures à plumes il
fossiles de dinosaures à plumes voilà on
a toute une variété de fossiles qui
s'offre à nous donc les microraptor
notamment avec leurs plumes très
évidente mais on a aussi évidemment
l'archaeopteryx qui ressort et et celui
ci voilà le sinosauropteryx qui fut l'un
des premiers découvert avec ce petit
pelage ce petit plumage sur le dos donc
bon monique eu c'était un choix fort peu
judicieux par le magazine times
il faut bien l'avouer d'ailleurs dans le
même mois la revue science news publia
un article proposant l'hypothèse qu'il
s'agissait plutôt d'un animal fouisseurs
ressemblant plus à une taupe
ouais bof par ailleurs en 1993 par
ailleurs en 1996 les journaux
rapportaient à la découverte en chine
d'un fossiles de reptiles qui aurait
possédé des plumes certains médias
affirmaient même que sous réserve de
confirmation ce fossile représenterez
une preuve incontestable que les oiseaux
d'aujourd'hui sont descendus des
dinosaures
l'un des scientifiques se hasarda
jusqu'à affirmer il est impossible d'en
conclure autrement il s'agit bien de
plumes cependant l'académie des sciences
naturelles de philadephie à xp expédia
une mission composée de quatre
scientifiques de premier rang chargé
d'examiner cette trouvaille cette
mission conclut au contraire qu'il ne
s'agissait pas de plumes bref selon un
rapport des médias l'un des
scientifiques affirmant qu'il avait vu
des structures ressemblant à des poêles
n'ont pas de poils proprement dit sinon
des éléments qui auraient pu soutenir
une collerette ou une crête comme chez
league one way c'est un faux positifs
parmi tant d'autres toutefois cet
article avait à peine paru qu'un autre
rapport des médias soutenait qu'une
vingtaine de fragments d'os d'un reptile
avait été découvert en amérique du nord
démontrent que les dinosaures serait
apparenté aux oiseaux or les oiseaux
sont des animaux à sang chaud et les
évolutionnistes qui se réclament de la
théorie de la transformation des
dinosaures en oiseau voudrait considérer
que les dinosaures étaient également au
mais au terme afin d'étayer leur
hypothèse cependant le docteur larry
martin de l'université duke octave
kansas s'oppose à cette supposition des
travaux des recherches récentes
démontrent que la structure ministre
microscopique des eaux des dinosaures
est propre aux animaux à sang froid
affirme le dr may
in ce qui nous ramène à la conclusion
que les dinosaures a été bien des
animaux à sang froid
oui bah le docteur martin il raconte des
conneries parce que les dinosaures c'est
quand même plus qu'un seul animal il ya
quand même des dinosaures qui étaient
gigantesques et avait effectivement en
face ils avaient été complètement à sang
chaud ce serait complètement cuit de
l'intérieur tellement ils étaient
énormes et puis à côté de ça vous aviez
des tout petits dinosaures qui était
effectivement recouverts de plumes et
qui eux ont une structure osseuse qui
est typique de celle des animaux à sang
chaud
donc effectivement si on réduit la
diversité des dinosaures juste homo
dinosaures en considérant que c'est
qu'une espèce
eh ben on dit du caca voilà mais bon le
docteur martin dans cette phrase en tout
cas néglige totalement la l'immense
variété des dinosaures qui existent dans
le monde et que si on étudie les
théropodes par exemple les bains ils ont
tous une structure d'animal à 100 au
moins partiellement chaud ou
complètement chaud il est pourtant
triste de constater que les médias laïcs
sont devenus tellement dogmatique dans
leurs prises de position anti
chrétiennes et pro evolution east au
point qu'il s'attarde à publier des
sottises du genre les perroquets les
quais et les colibris sont également des
dinosaures mais les perroquets les
colibris sont effectivement des
dinosaures au sens philosophique éthique
du terme puisque leurs ancêtres était un
dinosaure tu appartient à la même
famille que ta grand-mère et bah c'est
la même chose pour les colibris
d'ailleurs plusieurs autres articles
plus récents sont venus mettre de
l'huile sur le feu dans le débat oiseaux
dinosaures entre évolutionniste l'un
d'eux concerne les travaux les
recherches sur les origines embryonnaire
des doigts d'oiseaux et de dinosaures
démontrant que l'évolution des
dinosaures en oiseau est impossible de
plus une étude soit disant des plumes de
dinosaures de chine alors attendez c'est
douala c'est tout ce qu'il nous dit sur
les doigts donc en gros il a il a
certainement rien pigé à l'histoire
parce qu'il s'attarde pas à nous en
parler
ah et pour une fois par contre ici une
vraie référence donc ça pour ça un petit
un petit big up là pour une fois il cite
pas son magazine créationnistes favoris
et cite une vraie référence donc le
journal nature vicente schaffter qui est
un journal à impact factor et à comité
de lecture donc l'histoire des doigts
bah elle est très simple cette histoire
des doigts quand on regarde l'évolution
des dinosaures depuis les dinosaures du
trias jusqu'à ce qu'ils ont donné
jusqu'à ce qu'ils sont plus proches des
oiseaux on constate que ils perdent des
doigts ils perdent les deux doigts de la
perdre les deux derniers doigts de la
main donc finger évolution dinosaures
vous mettre une petite image quand même
l'histoire de qu'on comprenne un peu
mieux donc voilà web
celle là elle sera très bien donc voilà
les dinosaures ils perdent leurs doigts
jusqu'à atteindre le point où il ne
reste plus que le doigt 1 2 3 c'est à
dire le pouce l'index et le majeur donc
au départ il y avait un deux trois
quatre cinq doigts normal donc ça c'est
l'évolution normale des doigts chez les
dinosaures ce qui est on arrive toujours
à suivre quel est le doigt un parce que
le doigt le doigt 1 est le plus gros en
gros est légèrement opposable comme vous
pouvez le voir sur cette image là donc
le doigt étant légèrement opposable on
arrive à suivre lequel il doit 1 est à
dire qu au final les trois doigts qui
restent sont les doigts 1 2 3 il ya
aussi qu'on voit très bien aussi comment
se réduisent les doigts cat et 5 voilà
ils deviennent relictuelle puis
disparaissent complètement
or le problème c'est que la façon dont
on interprète les embryons d'oiseaux
c'est que quand leurs mains se développe
on sait que le doigt un est censé être
aligné avec avec le radius or chez les
oiseaux il ya pas de doigt un aligné
avec le radius donc vu que ya peu et ça
ça pose problème
et du coup est par contre on est censé
avoir le doigt 4 aligné avec lui il n'a
ou le cubitus donc chez les oiseaux il
n'y a pas deux doigts 1 aligné avec le
radius on passe directement au doigt
deux le doigt 3 et le doigt 4 qui est
aligné avec le cubitus et du coup ça
fait dire aux ans
jean qui étudiait les embryons qu'en
fait les doigts chez les oiseaux c'était
juste c'était les doigts 2 3 4 et pas
les doigts 1 2 3 vous avez la main d'un
juvénile quoi c'est ici pour y accéder
au crif se voit un semis opposable le
doigt de le doigt 3 qui a un peu réduit
et quand il est quand il devient adulte
le webzine voilà ce que devient ça
devient typiquement un aileron de poulet
et après quand vous regardez chez denon
x chez les dinosaures voilà le type de
mains que vous rencontrez eh ben vous
voyez que c'est il n'y a pas besoin
d'énormément d'imagination pour aller de
l'un à l'autre je veux dire voilà donc
le débat il est juste sur quel est le
doigt un qu'elle elle doit de et qu'elle
doit 3 au final
alors bon bah chez les dinosaures la
série évolutive semble suggérer que ses
doigts un doigt de droite 3
l'embryologie suggère ce que ses doigts
deux doigts trois doigts coach chez les
oiseaux mais au final c'est juste une
histoire d'alignement avec leurs adieux
cellule n'a quoi donc c'est pas non plus
un obstacle gigantesque à l'évolution de
la main et en l'occurrence il y a eu des
articles publiés qui ont qui ont très
bien traité cette question donc il n'ya
pas de y'a pas y a pas d'impossibilité
biologique dans l'évolution des doigts
des oiseaux il ya rien de tout ça le
dire de plus une étude sur les
soi-disant dinosaures à plumes en chine
révèle que ces dinosaures possédait un
poumon et un diaphragme typiquement
reptilien est très différent des poumons
aviaire rétention d'un caractère
primitif ne démontre rien voilà vidéo
sur le marsupilami
à chaque fois je vais vous renvoyer aux
vidéos qu'on a déjà fait sur tous ces
sujets parce que ce sont des arguments
éculés
selon un autre rapport les bords
irréguliers de ces fossiles chinois que
certains pensent être des plumes
ressemble aux fibres de collagène qui se
re qui se trouve juste en dessous de la
peau des serpents de mer
bah je vais vous remonterez juste je
vous remonterez juste le fossile de
micro raptor un juste pour me juste pour
vous me disiez que c'est du serpent de
mer
voilà allez-y allez-y les gars voilà on
reprend celui-là allez-y les gars sortez
moi l'argument du serpent de mer
je vous attends madame essayé de me
convaincre ça c'est des replis de peau
comme un serpent de mer chez paco al
bazi ainsi il n'existe aucune preuve
crédible que les dinosaures se serait
transformé en oiseau nom n'existe on a
juste ici une preuve très crédible que
tu as juste rien compris ou que tu est
de très mauvaise foi en effet les
dinosaures ont toujours été des
dinosaures et les oiseaux des oiseaux à
essentialisme te voilà enfin ça faisait
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas vu
et s'il en trouvait à dinosaure
fossilisé avec des plumes et ben ça
s'appelle un archéoptéryx si madame
c'est vrai archéoptéryx squelettes de
dinosaures recouverts de plumes il a des
dents une longue queue il a tout du
dinosaure plus les plumes
cela pourrait-il que les oiseaux est
évolué à partir de dinosaures et bien
non waaa temps si on écoute cet argument
magnifique et bien non un canard par
exemple est doté d'un bec et de pattes
palmées tout comme l'ornithorynque
pourtant personne ne croit que cela
prouve une évolution du canard en
ornithorynque mesdames et messieurs
allez sur e-bay achetez vous un fusil et
suicidez vous parce que là il n'y a rien
d'autre à faire non éteignez la vidéo je
voulais dit tout à l'heure d'étendre la
vidéo elle était finie déjà annoncées et
la haye c'est vraiment le genre de
phrase qui me fait me demander
vaut-il mieux entendre ça que d'être
sourd on va remettre en question le
vieil adage vaut-il mieux
sincèrement entendre ça que d'être sourd
bonjour j'y comprends rien en biologie
bonjour je vais écrire un blog
créationnistes où je vais expliquer
toutes mes théories de merde
[Rires]
le canard a des pattes palmées comme
l'ornithorynque whaou
bah c'est parce que l'ornithorynque
l'ornithorynque est classé parmi les
mammifères
parce qu'il allait de ses petits et
qu'il a des poils
il faut vraiment que j'explique des
choses comme ça et le canard est classé
parmi les dinosaures
parce qu'il n'est pas parce qu'ils
possèdent des écailles et qu'ils ne
rentrent pas or les animaux qui ont des
écailles et qui ne rentrent pas ce sont
les dinosaures
fuck you or pour justifier la croyance
selon laquelle des reptiles ou
dinosaures auraient évolué en oiseau il
faudrait trouver des écailles
reptilienne en voie de transformation
vers des plumes confère tout le registre
fossile que je vous ai présenté jusqu'à
présent c'est-à-dire des écailles
transitionnelle et non pas des plumes
entièrement formés alors est-ce qu'on va
réussir à retrouver cette image fait
leur évolution
voilà l'évolution des plumes
voilà il suffit de taper l'évolution des
plumes et vous les avez toutes vos
plumes transitionnelle à sa notamment ça
vient d'un article
là c'est cette forme de transition de
plumes là elle vient d'un article où on
a vu c'est le petit et nantes et nancy
en it in c'est celui-là ce spécimen la
voilà il a des petites plumes qui sont
complètement transitionnelle voilà donc
suffi voilà encore une fois google
images premières images qui sort
quasiment en effet à fos il ressemble à
un dinosaure est muni de plumes ne
serait qu'une curieuse mosaïque tout
comme l'ornithorynque
je ferme les yeux je ferme les oreilles
je ferme la bouche je vois rien jean
tauriel comprend rien
c'est à dire un élément de plus dans un
schéma présentant des similarités entre
les créatures dont le but est de laisser
apparaître la main de l'unique dieu
créateur qui a tous formés oui mais avec
des formes de transition pour te piéger
ce que dieu il est vieux il est malin il
est cocasse comme ça il est comme ça
dieu il fait des blagues il fait des
archéoptéryx il fait des ornithorynques
pour te piégé dieu c'est un marc en dieu
ne faut pas négliger l'humour de dieu
pourquoi est ce que c'est si important
mais parce que c'est ma religion qui a
envie d'y croire
des piles isatis ils font rien qu'à
m'embêter
s'il est vrai que les dinosaures sont
fascinants certains lecteurs pourraient
se demander pourquoi on en fait tout un
plat
n'y at il donc pas d'autres questions
plus importantes à traiter à notre
époque tels que l'avortement la
déchéance de la famille le racisme la
promiscuité la malhonnêteté des
comportements homosexuels l'euthanasie
le suicide de non droit la pornographie
jean-michel réac et du parminou nous as
tu rejoins oh oui il est là il est
puissant senti sa présence conques
ah oui on la sent bien il faudrait
plutôt parler aux gens de l'évangile de
jésus christ sans se préoccuper des
questions secondaires tels que les
dinosaures
oui et surtout pas être pdo surtout pas
pourtant les enseignements
évolutionniste sur les dinosaures dont
la société et si imprégné constituent en
fait l'un des obstacles majeurs
empêchant les gens d'écouter le message
de l'évangile ça rien à voir avec les
conneries tu dis tu es sûr c'est
peut-être pas pour ça que les gens
écoutent pas c'est parce que c'est à
cause des dinosaures c'est pas parce que
tu racontes de la merde t'es sûr d'où
l'abondance des problèmes sociaux de nos
jours la tendance des problèmes sociaux
de nos jours en effet si l'on ne croit
pas aux récits historiques de la bible
comment se fier à ces enseignements
moraux et à son message de salut si vous
ne croyez pas que dieu peut vous punir
alors comment pouvez vous être quelqu'un
de gentil
est ce que la peur du gendarme fait de
vous quelqu'un de meilleur
seriez-vous quelqu'un de
fondamentalement mauvais si vous n'étiez
pas conscient que dieu vous regardez est
ce que cela fait de vous une personne
plus morale d'être gentil parce que vous
avez peur de dieu c'est surtout ça la
question
vous avez deux heures par conséquent
celui qui accepte les enseignements
évolutionniste sur les dinosaures doit
également accepter l'idée que le récit
biblique de l'histoire soit faux bah
c'est parce que c'est pas parce que
c'est pas une histoire c'est une
mythologie et si en effet la bible se
trompe dans ce domaine alors elle n'est
pas la parole de dieu
on peut donc écarté toute autre
enseignement biblique qui nous dérange
si effectivement tout cette auto des
autos créé par des processus naturels
sans dieu alors nous n'appartenons pas à
dieu et par conséquent il n'a aucun
droit de nous dire comment nous devons
vivre
oui mais normalement si tu es quelqu'un
avec une moralité à peu près équilibrés
tu vas pas te mettre à tuer les gens
simplement parce que dieu n'existe pas
veut dire la moralité existe
indépendamment de dieu j'espère sinon on
est mal d'ailleurs d'après ce que
d'après ce type de raisonnement dieu
n'existe pas vraiment il n'y a donc
aucun fondement absolu de la moralité
sans dieu tout est permis le concept du
bien du mal n'est qu'une n'est qu'une
question d'opinion du reste sans
fondement moral le péché ne peut exister
or si le péché n'existe pas inutile de
craindre le jugement de dieu est le
sauveur jésus christ devient alors
superflus en effet la bible est
indispensable pour comprendre pourquoi
il faut accepter jésus-christ oui mais
encore une fois si ce site une est
gentil que parce que tu n'as peur de
dieu est ce que tu es vraiment un gentil
est ce que tu mérites vraiment le
royaume des cieux se discute des
millions d'années versus l'évangile
par ailleurs la doctrine selon laquelle
les dinosaures auraient vécu et disparus
des millions d'années avant l'apparition
de l'homme constitue une atteinte
directe aux fondements de l'évangile
donc non encore un autre sens en effet
le registre fossile dans laquelle
apparaissent les dinosaures parmi
d'autres créatures fait état d'un passé
de morts de maladie de souffrance de
cruauté de brutalité à savoir un passé
tout à fait atroce ah si celui qui a
nommé la thèse de milan non parce que ce
qui est raconté dans la bible c'est
gentil non parce que c'est sympa ce qui
se passe dans la bible aussi est-ce
qu'on peut à ce qu'on peut en parler
un peu des belles histoires qu'il ya
dans la bible notamment l'ancien
testament parce que bon le nouveau
testament on est d'accord c'est
gentillet mais mais l'ancien testament
quand même là non ce gentil un bref
ainsi celui qui admet la thèse des
millions d'années est contraint de
reconnaître qu'il y qui lui la mort
l'effusion de sang la maladie la
souffrance avant le péché d'adam oui
mais c'est ce n'est mal que dans ta
culture occidentale moderne
pourtant la bible est formel la mort
l'effusion de sang la maladie et la
souffrance sont des conséquences du
péché en effet la lors de la malédiction
qui le prononce dieu dira dans de la
jeunesse en votre blablabla blablabla là
c'est du prosélytisme et l'apocalypse
précise un nouveau ciel et bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla bref s'il ya eu
des dinosaures et les dinosaures il
était carnivore alors il se manger entre
eux et puis c'est pas très catholique
voilà
conclusion si nous admettons que la
parole de dieu à partir de la genèse est
vrai alors dieu existe et les dinosaures
ont vécu en même temps que les êtres
humains donc ya pas de problème voilà
c'est ce que je disais sur l'argument
circulaire depuis le début si on admet
que la jeunesse est vrai alors j'ai
raison et puis voilà
non c'est quand même magnifique d'avoir
une conclusion qui commence par si nous
admettons que la parole de dieu à partir
de la genèse est vrai alors j'ai raison
et qu'elle fait donc autorités alors
nous pouvons expliquer les dinosaures et
interprété deux fois sans cohérente les
faits que nous observons dans le monde
qui nous entoure
ah je te la fais la même avec la licorne
heureuse si nous admettons que la
licorne euros existe mais qu'elle est
invisible
alors on ne peut pas l'avoir mais elle
existe quand même ta gueule j'ai raison
ah didon ça marche aussi
or par sa démarche
nous aidons nos semblables à savoir que
la genèse est entièrement digne de notre
confiance est défendable pas un
raisonnement logique et de surcroît
qu'elle est ce qu'elle est prétend être
à savoir un récit exact de l'histoire de
l'univers et de l'humanité au demeurant
ce que nous croyons au sujet du livre de
la jeunesse conditionnera à terme notre
attitude face au reste de la bible ce
qui à son tour influencera notre vision
de nous mêmes
notre manière d'appréhender les autres
et le sens que nous donnons à la vie y
compris à notre besoin de salut et à
propos de salut salut
et
ou c'étaient des bonnes kg pénitence j'y
suis arrivé ça a pris trois heures
c'était douloureux mais on y arrive et
je vous dis au revoir merci d'être resté
jusque là si vous y avez survécu
sinon c'est que vous avez acheté un
fusil sur e-bay et ja et à ceux qui sont
encore là je dis à la prochaine fois